uh good evening members
officers and members of the public and
welcome to this planning committee
meeting on
the 18th of may
as always i have to give a little bit of
housekeeping
so we keep safe if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices via
the stairs
by opposite the lifts please do not use
the lifts and also you can use the door
to my right to your left assemble on the
green in holy square
and an officer if deemed safe will come
and tell you to come back into the
chamber
where we can carry on i don't think
there is any
planned fire alarms tonight
filming does anybody wish to film this
meeting tonight could they please show
their hands
thank you very much
uh
restrictions obviously are mobile phones
i asked you all please to turn your
phones to silent and they must not be
used during this meeting
uh for calls or emails and so on i would
ask you to do that please
members requesting to speak under
council procedure
20.1
i have council austin and councillor
nixie who are both asked to speak on
item 4a
are there any other members who aren't
on the committee
uh wishing to speak under cancer
procedure 20.1
i don't see any hands thank you very
much
public speaking the foreign applications
have been reserved for public speaking
with members please strike through and
make a note
of the following items on the agenda
item
4a berth 4 and 5 port of ramsgate
item 4b
7 seacroft road brawlstairs
item 4c
2 to 12 harold road in margate
if you make a note of that please
agenda item 1 apologies for absence i
have apologies from councillor orban and
i believe i may be wrong here that
councillor curry was stepping in
his councillor curry
he has okay councillor everett thank you
apologies from councillor gerald bayford
and welcome to
councillor roy dexter and thank you
councillor dexter
agenda item 2 are there any declarations
of interest
please show
thank you members
counselor is asking just a question
chair on uh on uh declarations of
interest on the uh
item foray
cancer everett i believe was leader when
he was uh
doing a lot of things with uh with the
port
would he not be conflicted in this
i am going to take advice um councillor
rozewski thank you
we do have our legal officer here
uh tonight council rusevski um please
estelle thank you
thanks very much your question um this
is a matter that i've discussed with
council forever prior to this evening
um it's not really
if anything it wouldn't be considered a
conflict of interest it's more an issue
of whether
councillor everett or anybody else in
the room who's previously expressed a
particular review
view on the matter
would be considered perhaps to be
predetermined
but there is a
under the localism act section 25 there
is and i can provide that for you after
this meeting if you like
there is a legislation that states that
no counsellor
shall
be considered to be predetermined simply
because of an expression of a previous
view on a matter so when taking a
decision
it is accepted that councillors may have
ex previously expressed certain opinions
either way provided that they come to
the meeting with an open mind and
there's nothing that i've seen in
discussions with councillor everett
before this meeting that would suggest
that so it's fine
uh thank you estelle
um
i hope that answers your question there
councilorski um
so moving on again to agenda item three
the minutes of the planning committee
held on the 16th of
april i think i've got march down here
but this is the man who writes this out
for me a bit of a smack later
the members agree that the minutes of
the planning committee
held
in april
uh our approved
correct record
could i have a proposal please
several hands council common cook a
second to please
council
uh do you all agree
thank you
sorry about the month being wrong i
think we're all over the show at the
moment thank you
uh i'm gonna hand over to uh mr
livingston our plan applications manager
for a point of information
thank you chair a point of information
on on two of the items this evening
on schedule item 4a the officer
recommendation on condition 5 is to be
added to so currently the condition
states that prior to works commencing on
site a pre-commencement breeding bird
survey must be carried out within the
portland harbor area if any breeding
birds are present and will be disturbed
by the construction work all works will
cease until the all young have fledged
the recommendation is altered so the
wording would state prior to the works
commencing onsite a pre-commencement
breeding bird survey must be carried out
by a qualified ecologist within the
portland harbor area if any breeding
birds are present and a judge by the
ecologist to be disturbed by the
construction work all works must cease
until all observed young have fledged
the ground of that is in order to
safeguard a protected species in
accordance with the advice in the
national planning policy framework
an additional point of information on
agenda item 4c which is 2 to 12 howard
road
condition 2 has an error in a reference
to plan
p 2
0
version b which should be
p113 revision b which is the floor plans
of the terrace of properties
and plus an additional plan
which is p212 revision d which is the
ground floor plan of the flats should be
referenced so all of these plans are
online and will be shown to members this
evening so the condition wording is
therefore updated to reflect these plans
thank you chair
uh thank you mr livingston
uh item agenda um for schedule of
planning applications and the public
speaking
members if there are any site visits
decided tonight um they will be on the
10th of june uh that is i think you're
aware
um a week later than they normally would
but um
on the third of june i hope everybody
will be celebrating
for her majesty the queen so it is a
bank holiday weekend so it's the 10th of
june for any
site visits
agenda item 4a is the application for
approval of birth 4 and 5 at the port of
royal harbour ramsgate on harbor
approach
speaking
an objection to the application is mr
murphy mr murphy are you there good
evening mr murphy you have three minutes
please thank you
and if you push the button in front of
you on your microphone we'll all be able
to hear you
thank you thank you chair
i speak as a ramsgate resident and on
behalf of the ramsgate regeneration
alliance
we object to this application because it
is seriously flawed
we believe the applicant has misled you
the marine management organisation and
the public
so far as we can see
it is not
permitted development
under the town and country planning act
environmental impact assessment
regulations of
2017 projects including vessels over 1
350 tons cannot benefit from permitted
development rights
vessels supplying brett way more
so the application falls
on permitted development we understand
that the applicant has obtained
independent legal advice
but this has not been disclosed to us
and more concerning my understanding is
it hasn't been disclosed
to
to councillors
we believe
that members of this committee should
see that advice before deciding the
application
if it is treated as permitted
development
it will create a dangerous precedent
because it will pave the way for other
applications in the harbour without the
transparency independent checks and
scrutiny of your full planning system
however
even if even if none of these matters
are of serious concern to members of the
committee we still believe the
application should be rejected because
one
the proposed new position is one of
heavy and continual silting and will
require regular
dredging but there is no proposed
mitigating strategy
secondly the design is not like for like
the proposed structure is much longer
and larger with a capacity seven times
more than before
brett doesn't need it
brett didn't ask for it but tdc say
brett will be the sole user so
why do it
now this may not be a planning issue but
it's certainly influential the cost
is 280 percent more
than a like for like alternative so
members of the committee for all of the
above reasons we would invite you to
reject the application
however even if you're minded to accept
it we would submit
that if you have any uncertainties about
it at all
then it would be appropriate to refer it
to the secretary of state
for an independent determination
thank you so much for your time and
attention
uh thank you very much mr murphy thank
you
uh speaking on behalf of ramsgate town
council is town councillor greene
councillor greene
thank you chap
romney town council considers the
application before you to replace birth
4 and 5
of such importance that to the town that
we have taken the unusual step of
requesting permission to speak to you
we have some sympathy with you as
members of the planning committee
due to your unusual position of being
both applicant and examining authority
as the applicant tdc appears to have
taken your approval for granted
in that is it has already decommissioned
the function in existing birth in
november 2020
and spent a huge budget on a secondhand
floating part two
as a replacement
we ask you to put aside in routing your
decision
any consideration of the unfair position
your administration has put you in
as you would any other applicant that
had foolishly committed upwards of two
million pounds to a project without
planning permission or a business plan
yes tdc has a contractual obligation to
brex
not incidentally a planning
consideration
however this could have been met by
repair of the existing birth
a replacement like for like
estimated to have cost around 400
000
or a negotiation to terminate the
contract cost unknown
the old birth
supported a 40 temporary conveyor and
was capable of ducking 90 meter vessels
it is planned that the new bath
will be fitted with a permanently fixed
3000 ton per hour conveyor belt and be
capable of ducking 120 meter vessels
the applicant explains quote
this is to facilitate
future expansion for the london of bulk
cargos
the trafficking of mobile plant whatever
that means and with a life span of 30
years
the town council considers that the
applicant's claim that this is like for
like replacement is not justified
the new birth would be
three thousand times
three thousand percent bigger three
hundred percent bigger than the old and
the conveyor capacity seven seven
hundred and fifty percent greater
at capacity the environmental impact
through increased noise and dust on both
the residents and the environment is
very concerning
atomic council is the planning authority
is undertaking a revision of the local
development plan as well as the review
of the future ramsgate port lab
the limited amount of consultation to
date does not support any increased
environmentally damaging activities in
in the port
indeed many including the town council
think that the future lies in increased
recreational activities
your approval of this application unless
you make severe restrictions on the use
and capacity of the facility
restricting use to one over
one owner
one user sorry restricting the type of
materials that can be unloaded
the hours of use the amount of material
unloaded and the road traffic generated
will potentially close many of the
options for an exciting future for
ramsgate seafront
thank you for listening
thank you councillor greene
speaking under council procedure 20.1 uh
councillor austin
thank you sir thanks for the opportunity
to speak about this planning proposal in
my ward obviously as has been
highlighted we're making this
application to ourselves so it's
particularly important that we're
transparent and go into this in full
full and detailed consideration
we've produced an impressive series of
reports from specialist consultants
showing technical aspect of the impact
of this proposal but i believe something
very important is missing from the
information in front of you a business
plan showing how we expect the new
facility to be used which is surely
central to its likely impact
personally i've found the documentation
on how the facility will be used
puzzling it's been highlighted that
we're not really looking at a like for
light replacement
in the marine license documentation on
the one hand the hra report says the
expansion does not represent an
objective to increase the birth capacity
but the noise and vibration report
clearly refers specifically to future
intensification quotes of brett's
activity and the increased noise as a
result
yet we know from councillor bayford's
response when he was leader to a
question by councillor wing that bretts
have not
requested a bigger facility and when
councillor everett was leader he assured
us that cabinet had no plans for
increased activity at burst fall and
five i'm not aware of any change to this
policy that has been announced since
then so my question would be can any of
us as members of this council explain
with any degree of confidence why we are
doing this
a like for like replacement would have
cost around six hundred thousand
why particularly at a time when council
budgets are greatly overstretched and
our residents are exp facing increasing
hardship
would we be considering spending 3.2.3
million on an excuse expanded facility
for which as far as i know none of us
has actually seen a plan even showing
the anticipated income to set against
this spend let alone the environmental
and social impacts of whatever proposed
use is planned surely this is the first
thing we should have seen long before
this stage
and does this not leave an embarrassing
gap in the information needed for a
planning decision
as well as this the fact that we as
members have seen no business plan for a
major development like this raises
serious concerns about our governance
and in this week of all weeks ensuring
proper governance should surely be
uppermost in all our minds
under these circumstances for members to
be seen marking our own homework and
giving it an a-star despite its evident
missing pages appears to me to be both
risky and wholly inappropriate might
have suggested the committee discovers
its decision pending site of a full
business plan to accompany the technical
information as without this surely no
properly informed judgment can be made
thank you for your time
uh thank you councillor austin
also speaking under council procedure
20.1 uh council linuxi
good evening thank you chair um
sorry to anybody that um is hearing
duplicates here there's an awful lot of
things that
various people are really quite
concerned about and especially those of
us that live in ramsgate so my objection
relates the operational phase of the
development and is based around the
environmental statement
firstly failure to consult stakeholders
in the environmental impact assessment
process i've asked people that live on
the cliff some of the hundred
residential dwellings that are
approximately 350 metres from the
proposed site
no one i spoke to has been consulted
during the process there are residents
of the direct sight line of the port and
be directly impacted with no
consultation they are rightly asking
councillors why not
along with that there's no mention of
the environmental survey of battenfall
london array and siemens which are based
on the port and have significant number
of employees
secondly there's a failure to establish
a proper baseline on air quality in the
environmental study
the district council is not and has not
monitored for particulate anywhere near
the site and nor has brett as far as i'm
aware crushed limestone which is a
source of
respirable crystalline silica is
sometimes stored out in the open on site
the environmental survey is inadequate
and there's been no baseline monitoring
of particulate or nitrogen nitrogen
dioxide near the site
as stated in the environmental survey
the nearest monitoring was both of both
actually was 1.38 kilometers away
it's not as though there's open country
between these monitors and the port
there are numerous buildings in between
thus making it simply too far away to be
a meaningful reading
according to
addresspollution.org saint augustine's
road is well over the level for
pollutants and according to the world
health organization's own suggested safe
limits i do have the specific
information for this if you needed it i
wouldn't read it out to you now but i'm
more than happy to give it to anybody
that would like it
the environmental survey fails to
consider cumulative impact of the wood
burning biomass plant
the port is at one site of peggle bay
and is a wood-burning biomass plant the
other side there's little
except open water between the port and
the biomass plant the predominant wind
direction is from the south
west and the direction of the biomass
plant it means that you know it
definitely impacts on ours and i just
don't see that environmental report
either
the environmental survey is predict
predicated sorry it's late isn't it on
the misleading assumption of a similar
level of operation i think you've heard
from everybody that it's not generally i
won't repeat on on that because other
people have done that before me and
thank you very much
um
and therefore as people have suggested
you know a huge increase in capacity
means a significant amount of more sand
more aggregate bought in more hgv
traffic and significant increase in the
number of ships coming to the harbour is
that in the environmental study i'm not
sure it is current operation of the site
is unsatisfactory therefore residents
have been trying to get something done
about this for a very long time and they
are wanting to be listened to my
conclusion to this therefore apart from
the fact that i object to it strongly
and is the application is unnecessary
it's a site visit and a meeting with
residents please thank you
thank you
thank you councillor nixie uh i will
call upon
mr livingston to give his report
then
thank you
so the application is for prior approval
for the installation of a
119 meter long berth following the
removal of births 4-5 and it's under
part 18
class a of the general permitted
development order so this part of the
general permitted development order
relates to works authorised by acts of
parliament and in particular the
relevant legislation here is the
ramsgate corporation act 1934
the hard rack 1964 and the rams gate
harbor revision order
1979.
so this part of the general permitted
development order requires a
consideration of the location of
development and the design and external
appearance of the development the
principle of development is agreed by
the act of parliament so in terms of the
site plan in front of members this is
identifying the location of the birth in
the port
we've got an aerial image there just
showing the port itself this is
obviously taken
a few
uh
you know some time ago obviously you've
got the cars there from when the the
port was used for uh vehicles being
unloaded um you've also got the the
existing bur or sorry the previous berth
that's actually present
where the mouse pointer is hopefully you
can see that
then we've got
a photograph taken more recently which
is showing out towards the the port
itself
if i can draw members attention to the
sort of center of the image you can
actually see the piles that have been
left
from the port berth that was previously
present
and this is the plan of the proposal
itself
so
you can see the extent of the previous
birth that's been removed uh the length
of the actual berth itself
would be 76 meters with then the gangway
attached to it of 43 meters you can see
there
and then this is the elevation of the
berth showing how it's to be attached to
the seabed so
as previously it's a floating berth um
the proposal includes the extraction of
the six piles that have been remained
from the previous berth
um what will occur is that they will be
cut off to lower than the seabed level
uh you've then got the construction of
four uh steel tubular piles two for the
gangway and two for uh sort of pontoon
restraints uh they'll install the
floating pontoon uh with fixtures um and
that will you know include then those
two fixtures for the gangways and that
will follow a a capital dredge uh as
well
so on the basis of the prior approval
process uh the consideration of the
location of development and the
development is in the same location as
the previous port berth
that was there so the location is
considered to be appropriate in terms of
in the port and in terms of
consideration of the design and the
external appearance as required under
part 18.
it's it's a floating pontoon with an
access gangway it's got limited
projection obviously above sea level as
you could see from the the previous uh
elevation
and therefore it's considered to be
entirely appropriate in terms of its
appearance in the port
so that
so the development itself
does however fall under schedule 1
development of the environmental impact
assessment regulations
which is when a threshold is reached
then it will require an environmental
impact assessment to be carried out
which is necessary before any approval
can be granted to a project
by a local planning authority
so we've had the environmental impact
assessment in that followed a scoping
exercise that was carried out
um
last year
and particularly that focused and scoped
in some issues that are covered in
detail in the environmental impact
assessment so those matters that were
scoped in include marine ecology
ornithology marine water and sediment
environment noise and vibration air
quality cumulative effects and then a
number of matters covered by the
legislation so habitat regulations
assessment marine conservation zone
assessment as well as including a flood
risk assessment
so as part of the consultation on the
eia particular requirements are in place
for an environmental impact assessment
and consultation that's needed we've
consulted with the responsible bodies
and the council received comments from
natural england the marine maritime
organization the environment agency
we've also received the views of kcc
biodiversity
tdc's environmental health team and
kcc's mineral waste as well as the views
that we've received from residents and
the town council
these are all outlined in the report so
you'll have seen those those views and
those and those points
so in terms of the environmental impact
assessment one of the key documents
that's been submitted which has been
looked at in a lot of detail by those
statutory consultees is the construction
environmental management plan so
this is because the construction of the
piles and the dredge
that's needed before that has the
potential for the most significant of
the impacts on the environment from the
construction of this particular birth so
that document as i mentioned has been
cited by consultees as required
mitigation
and in particular some of the issues
that have come up through the individual
topics assessing these matters
have flagged up particular things that
must occur for the development to avoid
an impact on the environment uh in
particular
the actual uh piling of these these
tubes um has been cited um by a number
of um of those consultees as potentially
causing a significant effect on the
marine environment in particular with
regards to fish and shellfish marine
mammals and bird species and therefore
there are specific requirements in the
construction environmental management
plan which relate to the need for a
marine mammal observer
there's also a requirement which is
under condition four which members have
before them which is the need for soft
start piling for the piles itself so
that's where there's a gradual increase
over time
with a low stroke with regards to hammer
rather than an immediate loud noise from
the the piling that's occurred um which
obviously means that there's
less disturbance always an increase that
allows
marine and you know the marine uh
species such as fish to to sort of
effectively move away because of the
underwater noise that would be created
in regards to birds though there's a
number more requirements that have been
requested by both natural england as
well as kcc biodiversity
and this is specifically to do with
that there isn't a wintering bird survey
that's been submitted in the
environmental impact assessment and what
that means is construction
for piling must only occur
um you know between effectively april
and august it cannot occur between
september and march when the wintering
bird season is
so that is a condition that's placed
would be put on the prior approval
in addition there is a the extra
condition which i mentioned earlier in
the point of information which is
talking about the requirement for a
qualified ecologist to carry out a
breeding bird survey and this
specifically follows on from a concern
which is raised in the in the report
that you'll see from kcc biodiversity
about the potential for black red starts
in uh the poor area because they are
species that that can be found in
industrial and urban areas
and therefore and they are protected by
scheduler 1 of the wildlife and
countryside act
and therefore there is a requirement for
a survey to be carried out
so a number of other matters have been
raised both
they've been covered in the report but
they've also been raised this evening um
as well as the issues that have been
raised in the report itself so just to
cover off some of those matters and to
provide members a bit more information
there are proposed restrictions on the
actual development occurring through um
through restriction construction hours
for
both the actual operation on site and
also the piling that would need to occur
so in particular they are
proposed to be restricted
to
bear with me sorry um
for sight working hours it's it's 7 am
to
7 pm monday to friday 7 a.m till 3 p.m
on saturday with no working on sundays
or bank holidays the piling works though
so the noisiest works are restricted
though to 8am to 6pm monday to friday uh
8am uh to 1pm on saturday with no
working on sunday or bank holidays and
that is specifically obviously
referenced in the environmental health
comment which looks at noise in
particular from the construction of the
the birth itself
in terms of um reference that's been
made in the report um to
the use
and addition of a conveyor to the actual
port berth itself a conveyor is not
being considered within this prior
approval application it would require
separate approval from kcc
and as kcc are the mineral waste
authority so that would be a matter that
they would consider in terms of a
conveyor how it operates mitigation in
terms of dust etc for any aggregates
that come on to this birth that's so
that's the matter for the mineral and
waste authority
um in terms of consultation which has
been mentioned um the council has
as a local planning authority uh has
gone through the the various
requirements with regards to
environmental environmental impact
assessments
two adverts have been placed in the
paper three site notices have been
placed both one at the port one on royal
crescent
as well as one in the harbour 41 parties
who wrote in on the previous prior
approval application specifically
were directly written to about the
process and and therefore we have
covered not only the statutory
responsibilities of a local planning
authority for this type of development
but also we've exceeded it with regards
to consultation and indeed there has
been obviously been quite a lot of press
articles and things like that so we do
consider the consultation is robust
um mention has also been made of
the the need for this development the
motivation for this development that is
not a consideration for planning
committee it's not a matter that's
covered under the requirements
for a prior approval application and
indeed if it were a planning application
it would also not be a consideration of
planning committee
so it's just a really important point
with regards to the motivation of any
applicant and members will know this
from housing applications that have come
in
that is not a consideration the
motivation of applicant to put in an
application
in terms
of separate processes there is a
separate process that's required to go
through for issues to do with uh
dredging so the
in this instance is a capital dredge
that's carried out
and indeed the actual construction
itself is subject to a licensing process
a marine license which is being
separately dealt with by the marine
maritime organization
just to pick up a point that's been
raised with regards to
permitted development and the
interaction with the environmental
impact assessment regulations
this is specifically covered
in uh in the council's report that we've
put forward in terms of the application
process that members will have will have
seen there is a specific paragraph in
the general committee development order
which identifies that when it is
development under class a part 18 the
requirement that if an eia is needed it
automatically needs planning permission
does not apply
that's very clearly written in the
legislation
there is
mention has been made about the extent
to which the environmental impact
assessment that's been submitted is
adequate um it's been considered by all
of those statutory consultees that the
extent is adequate this is not a
consideration of the operation of brett
any other operations that go on at the
port that's not a requirement of this
environmental impact assessment and nor
is it a consideration for members of the
committee
in terms of
in addition to the environmental impact
assessment there is an interaction with
the habitat regulations so members will
be familiar with the interaction that
needs to occur for housing development
to avoid an impact of recreational
disturbance on the special protection
area so in the same way we have to
assess this development as to whether or
not there would actually be a
significant effect on the designated
sites when it comes to this particular
development
this is an image which shows the um
proximity to the designated sites um in
particularly uh importance is drawn to
members attention to the uh to the
hand side of the image which shows um
the green hashed as the extent of the
special protection area which is the
phallic coast and sandwich bay special
protection area
so in this instance the applicant has
submitted a shadow habitat regulations
assessment
which is outlined in the report and
looks looked at a number of issues
including the deposition of sediment
with samples carried out and now they've
been tested to
the required extent to which the dredge
would occur which is um under 4.5 meters
uh low levels of contamination were
found um but in the natural england
though looked at that shadow hra and
considered it to be insufficient in so
much that looked at the impact of how it
uh whether it embedded mitigation within
the work or whether or not mitigation
should be considered separately the
marine maritime organization carried out
a habitat regulations assessment as well
and that as obviously as part of the
license that they've got in at the
moment they identified that there would
be a likely significant effect on gold
and plover little turn and turnstones
which are the qualifying species of the
features that relate to the special
protection area through potential noise
from construction so they carried out an
appropriate assessment and looked at the
mitigation that could be provided to
avoid that impact and that relates in
this instance to the soft start piling
so when that piling happens the method
of piling as well as the other issues
that are raised in the construction
environmental management plan and
they've stated that those will be
required to ensure there's no adverse
effect on the environment
that has been consulted with natural
england natural england have agreed that
that is sufficient mitigation and that
the shad and the habitat regulations
assessment and appropriate assessment
have been carried out appropriately
and therefore the recommendations you'll
see actually includes the need to adopt
that habitat regulations assessment
appropriate assessment as part of that
recommendation with the mitigations
already put through in the conditions
so
in summary
the design and location of the
development is considered to be
acceptable in accordance with with part
18 um with the assessments that have
been made and in particular with regards
to the comments of the statutory council
teas and how that's led to specific
conditions
he's is considered to ensure that
there's sufficient mitigation to avoid a
significant effect on the environment
and on designated sites
the application is recommended for
approval
with the adoption of the appropriate
assessment at annex one
thank you chair uh thank you ian
i move the officer's recommendation is
adopted could the vice chair please
second
oh second that's yeah thank you council
common cook
members so to you i'm sure we're gonna
have a few hands
councillor keen
thank you just a couple of points i i
want to clarify
what what about the point that was
raised by the gentleman over there
earlier about the size of vessel making
it not permitted development can you
sort of clarify that for me
and secondly i'm not going to pretend i
understand the dredging thing but is the
dredging something that has to be then
regularly done is that like a
maintenance thing or is it a once-off in
construction
they're my questions thank you
um so the the issue with the threshold
of vessel is what's triggered the need
for an environmental impact assessment
so
that was a an issue in terms of the the
birth being bigger being able to take
bigger vessels means that actually
it's exceeded the weight limit in terms
of the thresholds in the environmental
impact assessment regulations
so as mentioned that's why we've got in
this environmental impact assessment
as i outlined in the general permitted
development order it's it's clear that
in the case of part 18 applications it
doesn't when there's an eia it doesn't
automatically trigger the need for a
planning application to be submitted
so the threshold in this instance
relates to the need for an environmental
impact assessment
in terms of the dredge
so this has been looked at um in part by
us but obviously it's mainly a matter
for
the marine maritime organization in
terms of looking at the license so there
is a requirement for a capital dredge as
part of this because of the extent to
which they need to dredge for for this
in terms of maintenance there are
obviously there's already a license with
regards to dredging to some extent but
that is an issue that would be covered
specifically by the mmo or the marine
maritime organization in terms of
requirements under a license so it's
it's the mmo's point on that
uh thank you and councillor everett
yes thank you chair and i'm grateful to
counselor razeki for drawing attention
to my prior involvement in this
initiative
i think it's quite um interesting that
the position of the two main political
parties on the council has been um
in total accordance over this uh in
proceeding with this burst four and five
and the reason for that of course is
because there is a contractual
commitment to provide this birth and
that is the basis on which we're here
and i don't think any of us have got
great enthusiasm for spending council
money on a new birth to import aggregate
but nevertheless that's where we are i
wonder if um mr livingston can just
comment on a couple of things that have
been raised one is this issue of
referring the um
referring the matter to another
authority and this was put forward by
ramsgate town council it's been
mentioned tonight i mean those of us who
are regulars on the planning committee
are well aware that it's not unusual for
the council to consider
its own planning applications and that's
what goes on up and down the country
could you enlighten us as to whether
there is any process for the council to
refer the application to another
authority or to the secretary of state
to rather than take the decision itself
or does it have no choice over that and
the other thing is
there's obviously a concern about the
intensification of use of the birth
and i understand that and i think that
if people the general public at least
were reassured about the um usage of the
birth and the amount of throughput that
can go on and what other uses it to
which it might be put then some of the
public concerns
about this issue would go away
so i wonder is it possible for the
committee to condition
um the use of the birth along the lines
that have been set out as the intention
on the basis that there could be other
impacts if other things were imported or
very large additional amounts of
aggregate were imported or is that
beyond the scope of what we're doing
here
thank you so in terms of my view of the
point to do with referring it to the
secretary of state as as you mentioned
council ever it's it's commonplace that
when an application is submitted by the
council and indeed this committee has
considered an application
relatively recently for railings within
the harbour area
those applications are reported to
planning committees specifically in the
council's constitution that when the
council is the applicant it goes to
planning committee and those two
functions
are do need to be kept very separate of
local planning authority as opposed to
the council as the applicant indeed
that's why
one of the points i mentioned about the
motivations of the council in deciding
to pursue this application is not a
matter for the planning committee again
it's the point that the motivation is
not something that should be taken into
account
in terms of referring it to the
secretary of state
there is no procedure that i'm aware of
to do that the secretary of state
i would offer my professional opinion
would write back and say
this is for you to determine um they you
know in terms of taking applications on
we've referred actually and members will
recall the application at margot
football club where there was an issue
with regards to a sport england
objection
and in that instance we referred to the
secretary of state because that's
actually what we're required to do
because there's a specific procedure and
circular which outlines when you should
refer applications to the secretary of
state in that instance the secretary of
state declined to comment on it
and that's when they are actually being
asked to comment on it and adjudicate on
it but um you know it's it's
specifically in the constitution that it
can be considered by the council so it
should be done so by planning committee
um in terms of
the particular point about
restrictions on the operation
the application is
under the prior approval procedure that
um that assumes that the principle of
development is acceptable under the act
of parliament now
in this instance um when looking at
the operational use of that birth
the facilitation of the use of that
birth is not something that we're
considering again this point about
conveyor that's needed to actually move
the aggregates off and the throughput
concern about how much that might cause
an impact it's not a matter of the
consideration this committee is the
consideration entirely of kcc as the
waste and mineral authority
in terms of
any increase in operation of of the
brett's facility again that is a matter
that
you know could increase by road
obviously members will be aware that the
birth isn't there at the moment uh but
brett's is still operating um the
capacity of that is set entirely
separate from this application in terms
of what's being considered here under
the prior approval procedure is is the
designer location the fact that there is
an environmental impact assessment
that's been submitted means that we can
consider whether or not this development
would result in significant effect on
the environment as part of that eia has
looked at okay what does happen if
there's an increased capacity what
happens if there is a potential for more
hdvs for example
and it has been shown
in that that there is no significant
effect on the environment and that has
what we've been consulted with as we've
sent to the environment agency they say
there's low environmental risk we've
sent it to natural england they've
commented as well and indeed the habitat
regulations assessment goes into the
detail looking at this development and
does consider that it doesn't result in
us in a significant effect on the
designated sites so it's not something
that i think is justified under not only
under this procedure but i don't think
it would be justified in a planning
application to restrict it um as an
operation for the port which is
connected to separate land-based
activities which are covered by separate
consent regimes
thank you
thank you counselor over it
all right in your counselor king
uh yes i might be some time i'm afraid
because i've actually read the hundreds
of pages of the environmental assessment
on a day off of work actually but i'd
just like to clear two things up we were
already exceeding the the tonnage limit
for vessels prior to this this
the previous birth being uh removed and
we didn't have a marine license then in
fact there were no the only marine
licenses that were present on the mmo
site when i had a look nearly two years
ago were one for
a new berth that i believe either that
and fall or london array had put in and
our dredging licenses so we were already
operating illegally according to the
marine management organization and the
port the portal is very helpful
uh i'd like to ask a number of questions
for clarification but i'd like to ask
one question first of all why did tdc
decide to use general permitted
development rights with prior approval
approval and not go down a full planning
route given the historical
significance of us actually having a
cement bachelor with no planning
that sharon thompson confirmed in an
email has no rights to be there and had
no rights to general permitted
development and again i think it goes
back to the governance issue that
councillor austin brought up
if we're putting our own planning
application in then we should be abiding
by the highest level of due process
possible and let's go back through three
years we were even trying to get this
through without applying for a marine
license and that was down to the
tenacity of a few councillors and
residents
who knew that that was wrong
uh i i've got four pages of concerns so
i'd
how do you want me to do this read a
section and then get my questions
answered or
counseling if ian could come back home
first please um in terms of
the motivations of the applicant in
pursuing this
we the local planning authority isn't
the applicant so i'm afraid that's a
question you're gonna have to direct the
actual function of the council in terms
of the poor that's not that's not our
decision to adopt this approach in terms
of the application obviously we've
looked at it and considered that this is
something that can be done
but we're not the decision makers of why
that application has been submitted um
in terms of the the query with regards
to planning uh permission um i think in
terms of the transparency element and i
think this is a a point here that if
planning permission was to be sought
it would need an environmental impact
assessment just as it this has
and it would require the same level of
scrutiny that that this has
one of the things that we're not
considering
this evening is actually that point
about the principle of development if it
was a planning application you would
consider the principal development and
as you'll know um it's in terms of kcc's
waste and mineral authority they are
entirely supportive of this development
as it would be a safeguarded wharf again
though that's not it's in there in the
report because that's the comment we've
got but we're not considering the
principle of development um and indeed
not considering the local plant policy
which is sp 12 which would support this
development if it was a planning
application so it's it's about the
specific criteria of of the prior
approval that we're looking at i
understand that there's a concern that
we should have done as the council when
i say we the council should have
submitted a different type of
application but in terms of what members
are considering obviously it is what has
been submitted and again it comes back
to that point i raised earlier the
motivation of the application coming in
the decisions by different
administrations if they are is a matter
that's that's passed that has happened
the application is before the planning
committee to consider as it is
okay then i'll carry on so the covering
letter in the covering letter the
development is described as a similar
floating birth facility when in fact
it's different in a number of critical
features many of which have been
mentioned before so i'm not going into
them
it states the function will not change
and there will be a single operator the
existing lease lease holder however this
is at odds with what is stated
previously documentation including bulk
cargo and wood pellets which are a
concern
being possible imports
additional concerns over design and
location so the original application
the birth was uh
sat on top of the existing birth so in
could we go back to the image of the the
birth now it's rotated round so you can
clearly see and this raises a number of
issues that i don't think have been
considered in the environmental
statement because i think the
environmental statement started when the
birth was in the old position which is
sitting on top of the existing birth
this this document this this diagram can
be very confusing the entire red area is
the new birth
and that the squares i believe in the
middle are the conveyor is that right
so the squares that sit on the center of
the red berth of the conveyor because it
is a very confusing
uh diagram if you're a layperson i
sought advice on this also the the
numbers around the uh
the birth so all the little figures
around the birth are i think it's mean
tide
mean average tide so that's an
indication of
i mean low tide so that's an indication
of the levels of silt that exists
around that birth now you will see as
you look below the birth they go to nor
naught something there's a large number
and a small number further down they
actually go to minus numbers
so by rotating this pontoon round we are
we are going to increase the amount of
dredged silk we're going to have to
remove to put this berth in now we've
moved it we're also going to have to
uh there'll be increased dredging costs
as a consequence of that birth sitting
round don't forget this birth is going
to take significantly larger ships
uh the dc van lieden that visits there
there is a large ship actually it
discharges without a berth and it's
capable of discharging both gravel and
sand without a berth so i i'm odds to
know why we need this in the first place
so i don't believe the environmental
statement actually gives updated
dredging going back to the dredging and
the marine licenses we are hoping to use
the existing marine license that we have
for dredging and there are two we've got
two approved region sites one's in
sandwich one's in sandwich it's closer
and one is dover-based
we're hoping that the marine management
organization will just allow us to dump
our silt at these two approved sites and
i believe we've got a a certain capacity
and i think we're well under that but
what concerns me is there's been no
dredging of this area for the last two
or three years and i walk this cliff top
every morning and i can tell you most of
that lower part is completely silted up
so one of the concerns i have
uh is that we are going to be dumping a
significant amount of dredged silt
in one upwards i don't think they're
going to take it down to dover it's all
going to be on the peg well bay in a
short space of time two weeks whereas
dredging would have been a continuous
process over a number of months so
that's a concern i have there there's no
indication in the environmental
statement that the marine management
organization are going to allow us to
use that license to to do this
uh significant dredging over a short
period of time
environmental statement it's very
disappointing
that it's scoped out climate change
you know in in 2030
most of the most of a part of the port
according to kcc's own data will be
under water and i know i'm told but the
pontoons float
okay the pontoons float but the port
doesn't float and we have images we have
images at high tides of the water
encroaching already onto the sand piles
and aggregate piles that bretts have
on that site
so you know 2030 is not a long way off
so i have real concerns that we are
going to spend a significant amount of
money on on a project that is going to
be outdated pretty quickly or shall we
say overwhelmed with water
i don't think alternative considerations
have been have been mentioned
as i said
uh the dc van lieden
regularly off loads it i think it
attaches to the existing piles that are
already there from the old pontoon and
it discharges sand we're told from an
extension arm
part of that group there's the dc ostend
and the dc ostend which is part of that
dc group is capable of discharging both
sand and gravel without a pontoon indeed
i believe the britannia beaver bret's
own vessel is capable of discharging
both sand and gravel so there is no need
for this birth at all and need does need
to be considered and even if it's not a
planning issue it needs to be heard
because it's the people here that are
going to be paying this bill
also i believe that the the original
birth which was ripped out i think a few
days after it was confirmed an
environmental impact assessment would be
needed and that again was forced by a
few good councillors and residents
presently half of it was taken away i
think half of it was chopped up on our
own slipway and half of it is now
existing quite happily in another in
another harbor somewhere else you know
councillor everett quite rightly says
we've got a legal requirement to do this
according to our lease this is a spend
of 2.3 million i'd actually like to see
that lease agreement before i sign off
on any spend of public money
it's been refused me under a freedom of
information request that was 14 months
late so i go back to governance in this
council again i waited 14 months and
four of my e-work emails were ignored
it's just not on we should be given
confidential sight of that lease
agreement to be sure that we're spending
people's money in the right way
i've mentioned dredging so i won't go
into that again
ship traffic as i said before we were
already in breach of the marine
management organization because despite
the fact the original documentation said
one vessel visits the old pontoon
three vessels actually visited that
pontoon according to tdc's own records
on discharge of great aggregates
i it is nice to hear that the grey seal
and common seal will be protected so i'm
thankful for that and i do think that
this environmental statement is a well
is a thorough document and it was long
needed
i would like to ask that will all
records of sightings of seals be handed
to kemp wildlife and natural england so
that we can keep an eye an idea of the
impact on our on our
marine wildlife
birds i'm glad that we're doing an extra
study of the birds on that site because
it said there were no notable species or
assemblies of birds in the area and we
know that there are stalins were
regularly roosting on the port a lot of
them have disappeared now and there are
also formers nesting on the cliff close
by probably less than 50 metres from
that i'm also quite upset that into
project effects of cumulative impact has
not been assessed the only scoping tool
used here was a search of tdc's planning
pool tool which resulted in the
following statement there are no big
developments close by
we
because it's a a planning application
that we are putting to ourselves i fail
to see how we allowed an environmental
statement to not recognize the fact that
there is a cement business there is an
aggregates business there are two wind
farms i've noticed
uh walking along the cliff top because
now i've taken a keen interest in it we
have haulage people there we have
caravans being being stored there i
believe we also have somebody living in
a static green caravan that's part of
the haulage
one thing we miss completely is the fact
that we temporarily have a trav a family
of travelers there with a number of
legal processes in operation that need
to be completed before they're evicted
they have been
completely dismissed the impact on
workers or residents living on that site
have been completely scoped out of here
and that is a major failing in this
air quality so if we've got a map
i
actually i passed the noise and
vibration section i think was very well
done because they located three large
microphone looking things on the cliff
top i think one was near close to the
paragon one at some augustines and one
further down by the lookout cafe
so i think we can pretty much say that
noise and vibration was very much well
looked at
i fail
oh well i'm absolutely shocked actually
when it comes to air quality and dust
there was no monitoring monitoring close
to the site at all we used the existing
monitoring stations
the closest of which to monitor nitrogen
is on boundary road
1.35 kilometers away from the site
behind the most affected houses
the dust one is thanet ramsgate
automatic monitor i'm not quite sure
where that one is but it's 1.38
kilometers away the nearest properties
as defined in this document are
330 meters away which i am thankful of
because the short environmental
statement that was submitted when
brett's arrived said and i've got the
document here the nearest property is a
thousand meters away a thousand meters
takes in thousands of properties
it's a major
weakness silica i've been told is the
new asbestos
bets also do no dust monitoring on that
site so pn10 and pn
2.5
minute dust that can be inhaled and has
the potential to be carcinogenic it's
not monitored at all let's also state
that p75 doesn't travel that far i want
to know how they know that if they're
not monitoring and actually two days
after i read this document sand from the
sahara landed on my car so please don't
tell me dust doesn't travel we're all
livid about
we're all livid about detritus being
pumped into our seas from southern water
but it seems we're not bothered about
dust affecting our neighborhoods it may
be that that dust comes to the beach but
i'm not an expert none of us are in this
room and we need to make sure that
appropriate dust monitoring goes on
before we approve anything
sorry
it took me a long time to read it
i disagree
uh i disagree with the use of general
permitted development rights for two
reasons
one i don't think it's right for us at
tdc to be trying to use the lowest level
of planning to determine something
you cannot compare railings around a
harbour with a potential
increase in in in business and i don't
care it can be green energy i just want
due process to be followed so that we
identify potential risks and they are
mitigated against that is all i want due
process
uh a resident here said legal advice was
sought if that legal advice was sought
on general permitted development rights
can we have a site of that legal advice
so i cannot support this i cannot
support this development at the moment
for a number of reasons
there needs to be a
site visit appropriate dust monitoring
needs to take place so that we can
properly identify exactly what dust if
any is leaving that site and who it
might be affecting
we need site of the legal advice
and we need to make sure that cumulative
effect
takes into account all the users on that
site thank you
[Applause]
uh thank you very much uh counseloring
your very detailed report there but i'm
coming back to ian if i thanks i'll i'll
try and come back on on some of these
points um
the i mean i've already mentioned with
regards to i understand your perspective
counseling about the cost but obviously
as i mentioned earlier the cost is not a
matter for consideration by the planning
committee
in terms of scoping out climate change
um specifically this has been addressed
in the flood risk assessment so even
though it wasn't required a flood risk
assessment was provided
which has been looked at and again the
the
information has been consulted with with
the environment agency who would look at
these these matters um and it is
considered that that is satisfactory in
terms of um i'm not afraid i'm not going
to pick them off in a particular order
if that's all right um the
in terms of
um the concern with regards to
um
marine mammals observation with the arts
seals
indeed the construction environmental
management plan specifically mentions
about the requirements of reporting
records to natural england and chem
wildlife trust so that is a requirement
of the marine licensing conditions as
well
in terms of the the dredging
and
the impact on the dredging from the the
change that's been made um obviously the
actual dredge itself needs to be granted
a license by the mmo and obviously in
terms of the assessment of whether or
not the eia is sufficient as you'll see
from the report the mmo have deferred it
to the local planning authority but they
still need to agree it so if they don't
consider that's adequate and they don't
consider that the work that's gone into
actually making sure that the dredge and
what's taken out of there is uh is is
not um is has higher levels of
contaminants that means that the method
of disposal in particular areas would
cause impact on the environment there
then it indeed is a matter that would be
controlled particularly by them in terms
of the license in terms of the studies
that have been carried out that has been
looked at by um by both the mmo and also
through the eia in terms of the depth of
those samples that have been taken which
have been taken to the negative 4.5
which is obviously the extent of the
extent of the dredge that's that's being
carried out um so again
you know there are there are particular
guidance documents that are available
with regards to what the mmo have to
look at and i'm sure you're familiar
with them um with regards to the the
marine license and the sediment analysis
that is that is required in terms of
alternative options in the eia
the eia specifically
does look at the do nothing scenario the
basically the don't provide a birth
scenario so that is provided in there
and obviously as i mentioned earlier
there is a point that the the operation
of brett has continued whilst there has
not been a birth for the last few few
months so that is something that's been
considered in the eye and we do think
that is
is sufficient um in terms of um
cumulative effect of other developments
the eia is specifically looking at the
cumulative effect of this development on
and future developments so it's the
baseline looks at what's there at the
moment and if there's future
developments that's got consent uh then
they need to be make counted into the
assessment because obviously if i give
you that the housing example i suppose
would be if you've got a major housing
development that's been put forward for
an application and yet we've got 900
houses say down the road that's also got
consent but haven't started yet it needs
to ensure that actually the cumulative
effects on the transport network for
example need to be looked at so it's
looking at the things that haven't been
done and aren't operating yet um and
what that impact might be in in terms of
the development here so
in terms of the assessment of what needs
to be considered and what doesn't need
to be considered that's specifically
looking at major developments so that's
the developments that are likely to have
more of a significant effect on the
environment specifically those within i
think it was a kilometer or two
kilometers of the site
there are
coming but please uh members in public
if you wouldn't mind keeping your voices
down please while the officers speaking
thank you that's um
looking at the major planning
applications so more than 10 units
in of housing or more than a thousand
square meters and that is a a very
standard amount of threshold for what it
would be looked at in a cumulative
assessment in an environmental impact
assessment again these are the
developments that hit these thresholds
and that's what needs to be assessed
um in terms of
your point with regards to dust
monitoring again i've i've mentioned
earlier about the requirement of looking
at dust that comes from brett's is not a
requirement
of this
application or this eia
the operation that's going on at the
moment is is not what's being considered
here
but this is actually something that
you'll you'll have seen the
environmental health comment
specifically that deals with this issue
with regards to the baseline used for
the assessment which i appreciate you
don't agree with but it does outline
very clearly in in that in the comment
of environmental health why is
considered that the air quality
information that's been submitted is
adequate and that is the information
that's obviously been assessed by um you
know by the you know effectively the
advice that we rely on from the
professional experts on this so we do
consider that it's sufficient in terms
of the assessment of this particular
proposal um
i'm sorry i probably i've missed
probably some things but i don't know
whether you want to come back just come
up back at you on a couple
uh so the the noise and vibration
monitors were i would say within 200
meters of that site
forget brett's we then have to do an
assessment of dust in and around that
site
and we use
a dust monitor one dust well there's ten
of them but they don't all measure dust
there's only two monitors that measure
dust and the nearest is
1380
meters away the nearest property is 330
meters away i get it that the noise and
vibration is adequate we've got the
development
we have the noise and vibration meters
and we have
properties here when it comes to dust
we've got the development we've got
housing and then we've got the dust
monitor over here so forget forget
anything i said about brett's you cannot
that cannot be an adequate assessment
i also want to come back to you on on on
climate so
0.2.316 actually states the area is
vulnerable to wider environmental
changes due to climate change so there
is a there is a conflict statement
within that environmental section
also cumulative impact i i did quite a
lot on this and it's it's about the
impact that various things on a site
have
with each other and their combined
impact that they could have on the
people that live around so i sort of
disagree with you on that point as well
i'm afraid
uh thank you council wing
i think we're gonna have to agree to
disagree on
thank you for your comments there
counselor
uh wing uh counselor chris and then you
did raise your hand a little bit early
do you wish to speak now
yeah it was really just simply to come
back on just why is it so much bigger
can you just repeat that i know you've
covered that before um i was also going
to ask um pick up on councillor austin's
comment about business plan but i think
you've probably already answered that um
but thank you
um so again the
the
the need for it to be larger again that
the need and the motivations of the
applicant in this instance isn't isn't
the consideration of the of the this
type of application i mean the the
environmental assessment does
outline in in the applicant sorry excuse
me excuse me the applicant's view of the
benefits of it being larger specifically
with regards to
the the resilience to wave climax and
and providing more room for
larger vessels um
the in terms of the concerns that people
are raising about the increasing
capacity this is something that
obviously um
is is a matter that's for both the
operation um and that point about
business plan that you mentioned about
whether or not a business plan would be
needed um the there isn't a requirement
for a business plan to be submitted
again i think this this is where the
issue goes back to the decision of the
council as the applicant and that
decision being made to pursue this which
is not a matter that councils are voting
on this evening
and in terms of again this point about a
conveyor which would allow for a greater
rate of aggregates to be taken
that's obviously a matter as i say for
kcc in terms of the the physical
restrictions of the brett site to
actually store aggregate again it's a
matter for the operation of brexit
matter for kcc so
i think it's important that members just
look at what's being put forward is
fundamentally using go through a prior
approval process which uh considers
what's in front of them in terms of the
actual construction of that birth and
the um
you know how does that affect the
environment it's very clear that if
mitigation wasn't in place it would
affect the environment there's no
dispute in that and in the eia that it
says that and that's exactly why there
needs to be quite a bit of mitigation
put in place to avoid the impact of the
environment i will just pick up a point
about
the specific construction of the birth
in terms of dust from that process
is something again considered in the
environmental impact assessment and is
considered um again to be the methods
that have been put in place have been
considered sufficient by the
environmental health team as well so the
impact of the birth itself has been
considered by the eia and again we as as
the local planning authority we do rely
on our statutory council teas as
the
the people that are giving us the
professional advice and in this instance
obviously they have come back and
considered that the mitigation is
sufficient so
i'm sorry i can't answer the question
about the business plan again it's a
that is entirely an issue for the
applicant it has the motivation
to to pursue this what we've got to
consider is what's in front of us not
why we've got to where we've got to as
difficult as i appreciate i know that
members find it
it's this is a planning committee this
is not the cabinet of the council thank
you
uh thank you ian
are there any other councillorski
uh thank you chair um councilloring
suggested that um
maybe a site visit would be helpful um i
don't know if other members
feel that way but
i think maybe it would um it could be
that we need to propose that before we
go any further or do we
do that later
later
cancer it's asking if you may
i do i understand what you're where
you're coming from there but i think we
just move on
this moment
yes i will go through this first if i
may
um i don't see any other speakers um
thank you councilwing for your
comments um and i know other members
find that very interesting as well
but i have got to put this to members
now
the recommendation is for approval
with the members of the committee please
show if they agree show the hands please
sorry
i'm putting it to
sorry yes sorry the voice is going
tonight um
put in the two members those for
approval will show the hands please
those against
abstentions
check how can there be a decision
without a site visit surely
decision i make if there's going to be a
site visit we have to do this uh meeting
in a correct way
i i don't i i don't say it very oft
often but uh
it is it is thank you thank you and yes
sir
it is the motion that's on the table to
members which you've heard
and that is for approval
and it has been voted upon and that has
been
carried that has been carried members
thank you
thank you
if uh no no more
recorded please
record
first of all may i ask members of the
public please
please respect i know you have feelings
as everybody does and you have the right
to
i am following procedure tonight
i am following procedure in this
committee tonight and
i have done for the
shall we
i am going i just hope those that voted
in favor of it
please
please i'm going to stop and we will
have
a few minutes adjournment but that has
been approved thank you
uh so
i
i don't know i can't be rude i'm not
going to i'm not being rude to anybody
sorry
yeah i just like to ask for just for you
to clarify because
it's become very confusing to some if
not most of us
about
how we get
if we want the majority of us want the
site visit how we actually get a site
visit because previously
like the last meeting when we i think it
was leyland gap
it was mentioned before a vote that a
number of us would would benefit from a
site visit
and we agreed that oh yeah we'll have a
site visit we didn't vote on the motion
beforehand as far as i can recall now
one or two of us asked for a site visit
um
well one or two of the other members i
agreed with them i would have liked to
site visit
but you move straight to the vote for
the
for on the motion
and and it is if we seem to do things
differently at different committees uh i
i will come in i know mr sliverson will
come back
council ghana i think you know you've
been on committee for a while now
i have to go through the process as it's
laid out
put the motion what's in front of you to
start with
and
whether you agree and not agree or
abstain
we get a decision there but if it is
felt overall
regarding the site visit i have the
right to pull the motion
which is in front of you whether that if
that was for approval
i can pull that and that is my decision
and then propose a site visit and put it
to you
and i think you know i have to have a
proposal and a second
and that has to be agreed by
yourselves the committee
that's that's how it works and that's
how we've always done it okay okay how
do you understand what you're coming
from
i understand from what you're saying
then that whether or not we have a site
visit is entirely down to your your
decision
no no
no no it's not it's
i'll let uh mr livingston come in
just to confirm obviously with the item
that we mentioned you just mentioned
council garner um any proposal the
motion when it's on the table after
proposing and seconding the proposer
who's proposed it can
suggest to withdraw it they need the
seconder to agree and then potentially
put another motion forward
in terms of the site visit was was
wanted
then obviously the motion that's in
front of members would need to be voted
down
for then a new motion for a site visit
to be proposed and again as councillor
thompson says that that is how the
committee operates is how it's operated
for a while so in terms of the majority
view of needing a site visit um
obviously the vote has been passed and
so the majority view is to not have a
site visibility that's the next step
it's either site visit or it's refusal
for whatever reason that that's that's
suggested
happier
well no you yeah i can't ask i'll stop i
don't understand i'll stop you there we
have that isn't what happened at leyland
at the late in the game they did
it did yes it did
we'll speak
later if a bit confused um
ladies and gentlemen in the public
gallery i do apologize to you for
keeping you waiting but we are moving on
now to
um
agenda item for
4b
which is seacroft road brawl says
um
speaking as an objector this application
is a mr francis mr francis if you're
there please you have three minutes
uh mr chairman uh on being made aware of
the planning application we sought
professional advice in the letter of
objection prepared for us and submitted
on the 10th of march
we were advised that the proposed
development failed to comply with tdc
policies qdo2 and qdo3
having further taken professional advice
on the report submitted recommended
approval we have been advised that the
report in its content is subjective and
vague
the report contains inaccuracies
opinions and assumptions which are
clearly wrong and misleading some of
which i will outline this evening
based on the professional advice given
to us that the planning application does
not comply with tdc planning policies
concerns regarding submitted report
recommending approval and as advised by
councillor saunders we request the
planning committee to consider making a
site visit to understand the principles
of our objections prior to any decision
being taken
for your information four previous
requests were made to the case officer
concerning if we could be present at a
site visit none of those requests were
answered
the amended drawing does not in any way
reduce the impact that this plan
application will have upon us our
privacy overlooking and outlook
a first floor extension of the
full-length balcony would result in
unacceptable living conditions for us
from the balcony we were directly
overlooked when using our kitchen diner
entering them in our home as well as
when as well as when using our private
outside space
references made to the balcony providing
sufficient room for a small seating area
which together would obscure glazed
balustrade and this will remove any
overlooking by anyone sitting on the
balcony
there is no reference to people standing
or moving about in the balcony
the proposed balcony would face sea
woods they would not be unreasonable to
expect that this view to be taken
advantage of
our kitchen diner is the most used room
in our home
the case officer accepts the overlooking
aspect but is totally incorrect in
reporting that our kitchen window
currently provides a low level of
privacy
the case officer report states that the
current low level of privacy afforded is
due to persons walking past our kitchen
window to access the rear parking area
no one else apart from the co-owners
walked past our kitchen window this is
an accurate assumption made by the case
officer
the other two flats of joseph caught our
second homes and the owners visit
occasionally when they visit they park
their vehicles in seacroft road on the
rare occasions that they use the parking
area and they walk or drive past our
kitchen window it takes a matter of
seconds there is no impact on our
privacy whatsoever
this cannot be compared to that of a
balcony or permanent structure directly
overlooking us
access to the side and rear of joseph
court is a private area and as such is
only used by us 99. 99.9 of the time
the kitchen blind referred to in the
report is not lowered to restrict views
into our kitchen and is always open and
raised when we are home another
incorrect assumption made by the case
officer
we have a high level of privacy to the
side and rear of our house and have done
so since we purchased the property in
november 2017
this can be seen if a site visit were to
be made
number one joseph court is our permanent
home if planning permission was to be
granted we will have to live with the
constant uncomfortable feeling of being
overlooked a serious invasion of our
privacy we respectfully ask that
consider a site visit thank you for your
time
thank you mr pharmacist who time that
very well thank you
and i now ask the planet officer which
against mr livingston for his
report thank you chairman the
application is for the erection of a
first floor rear extension with uh
balcony over with a single story rear
extension as well at number seven seek
off road
so this is the application site um it's
sorry it might be a bit faint but it's
outlined in red
so to the um to the the right hand side
of the the photo here or that the east
of the site is
south cliff parade which is on the sea
front in broad stairs uh you can see
here the um the the property in question
um at the rear you have a single story
edition um and obviously an access as
well that goes to a property which is
number nine
uh sql throw which is the back
and the properties that's been
referenced is joseph's court which is
next door so on the right hand side of
that image to number seven
so the main issues for members to
consider are the impact on the character
appearance of the area but predominantly
the issue is the impact on the living
conditions of neighbouring properties so
this is a view of the front of um
the front of number seven at the moment
uh this is a view down the side so this
is down the side of joseph's court with
regards to the
um the the entrance door and and the
window at the back which we'll see a
more detailed photo of um in a bit which
has been referenced
um so proceeding down
um onto the parking court area that's
there's also been reference which is at
the rear
so this was a requirement of the
original planning consent for the um for
the building itself for parking for all
the units in the the three units they're
in joseph's core
then this is the view from the parking
court looking to the rear of number
seven
and you can see there the single story
existing accretion at the back
which is proposed for an extension to be
built on top of with a window and
balcony
reference has been made obviously to the
window in question um with regards to
this serving a kitchen the report very
specifically talks about the fact that
this kitchen from looking at the floor
plans from the approval is large enough
to constitute a habitable room so it is
primarily the main consideration that
members need to look at so whereas some
kitchens if they're small they don't
have dining facilities they wouldn't
need the required element of privacy or
outlook in this instance this is a large
kitchen so it does require um
consideration by members
in terms of the view turning basically
the other way and looking back towards
where the extension will be from that
window and that's the view that's given
of that area
and then this is a view looking down the
other side of joseph's court um which
shows where the entrance to two and
three joseph's corps so as already
mentioned by
mr francis
any resident that's part of the other
units would be walking around
from the parking area if they were to
use it round to the front of their
properties and round to the down to the
access to the side
so this is the current site plan
of the dwelling itself number seven
so this is just a plan showing the roof
plan with the extension going on top of
that single story element with the
balcony
in the the over the top of the single
story edition
so this is the existing side elevation
so members will recall the photo where
you saw the top of this this roof
what's being proposed is to build a
first floor extension with
double doors with window access mentions
been made to
the amended plans that have been
received so the balustrading on the
balcony has been increased in height to
1.4 meters with a requirement of them to
be obscure glazed
and this has been pointed out
specifically with regards to dealing
with prolonged overlooking from people
being able to sit on the balcony 1.4
metres in height means that anyone
sitting down wouldn't be able to
actually look out and down over the
balcony um indeed the point that's been
raised with regards to overlooking from
people standing that is a consideration
for members to look at as to whether or
not that would be frequent enough to
result in a significant loss of of
privacy
in terms of
the rear elevation of the
property
and then that's the existing and then
that's the proposed so the materials
that are proposed here is smooth render
to the ground floor
extension with um white cladding on the
um on the first floor extension
members will recall the image which is
that the property is is currently white
it's not got the cladding on it but this
development is around the back of the
property it's not going to affect any
wider views in the streets and it's not
considered to be obtrusive or resulting
harm to the character and appearance of
the area in our view
this is the
other elevations that the back end of
the extension um facing to the north and
again you can see that it's the
extension on top there with with the
cladding
so just to go through the floor plans
you've got the the existing kitchen
that's there at the moment
and then there's the existing first
floor plan which shows obviously at the
moment there's a bedroom with a
rear-facing window
and then the roof of the extension so
what's being proposed is for the kitchen
to be slightly extended
at ground floor level and with the
single storey addition
and then a balcony on top of that and
you can see the the width of that
balcony which is a meter
with a bedroom which has obviously the
double doors out facing towards the east
as mentioned the main consideration is
the impact on the neighboring property
at uh joseph's court um he has been
considering the report that um the
communal or the amenity space that's in
the corner of the site that you can
hopefully see by me moving my mouse
around
of joseph's court that area is is 21
meters away
from the balcony andy from the window
it's considered that by virtue of the
existing wall and then fence and also
the the relatively small depth of that
area that the actual balcony wouldn't
result in overlooking or certainly not
significant overlooking to that area to
result in the loss of privacy the
parking area at the rear isn't isn't
used as private immediately land in that
way so that's not a main consideration
but indeed the consideration is with
regards to particularly the kitchen
window at ground floor um now
in the submission that's been put in
separately the applicant has provided
this photo um so i do want members to
view this photo but not to put great
weight on it in terms of the judgment
because obviously what you can see from
this photo
is on the left hand side you can see the
eaves of the main roof
now in terms of the actual view that you
would get
from an extension that would be higher
up than this image so it's just really
important to state this is not the view
that you would get from that balcony
it's a higher up view that you would get
from the extension that's proposed
so in terms of you can see it there the
window the kitchen window in particular
the consideration by officers has looked
at the existing relationship um in
particular obviously as has already
mentioned the level of privacy afforded
to that window at the moment it's
obviously it is next to the um the main
entrance of the property and indeed the
access that's to the rear
for the parking area is would only be
used potentially by occupants of flats
two and three however um occupy
occupancy could well change it's not a
given necessarily that there's not
frequent movements using that parking
area it's not something that we could
certainly control in terms of that and
so that does mean that there is less
privacy than you would normally get from
a rear-facing window in a normal
property in a rear garden there's less
privacy than you would normally expect
in that instance
obviously there's also the particular
condition that's been required for the
seating area itself which would remove
overlooking from a prolonged basis of
people sitting out on a balcony
that's there so it is only the
consideration of whether or not the
balcony being used by occupants
would be so severe in terms of length
that it would result in significant
overlooking to that window or indeed if
the window of the doors themselves for
the bedroom would result in overlooking
into that window it is our view that the
angle that's present and you will have
seen an element of that angle in in the
photo that's that's been shown
would mean that if you're increasing the
the height of where this photo would be
effectively for your view that it would
remove it would reduce the angle of
which you would be able to see into that
window and again on the basis that the
prolonged overlooking that would be
created by the balcony has been
mitigated by the obscure glazing it's
considered that the impact of on
overlooking is not unacceptable
sufficiently unacceptable when
considering policy qd02 but it is the
primary issue for members to consider
whether or not that is their view or not
um there are safeguarding conditions
that are have been put forward
predominantly that relates to ensuring
that the actual balance trading goes up
before the balcony is to be used and the
recommendation um with those
safeguarding conditions is put forward
for approval thank you chair
uh thank you in uh once again i'll move
the officer's recommendation be adopted
because the buy share please second oh
second major
thank you council common cook members uh
castle heart
thank you i've been unusually quiet
tonight um
the only comment i've got about this um
is that why
even have the balcony i can understand
if you're standing on there and looking
out to the sea lovely view don't get me
wrong that's what everybody wants um but
if you're going to sit on that balcony
and it's 1.4 meters and if i'm i'm old
english so i think that's about that
height if that's about right oh higher
see
okay so you won't if you're sitting in a
chair you won't even be able to see the
sea
so what's the point of even having the
balcony so would it be better off um for
the people just to have what i think
they call it is it juliet balcony or
something like that where you just have
the doors now something that goes across
um so i can't quite understand the point
of it um and i live in a house where
people walk past my street and my house
and i live in a quiet road and they
still wave in my kitchen and say hello
through the window so i'm used to it um
and some of the people i i don't even
want to know where i live um so we do
put up with these sort of things and it
is life
but i just can't see the point of having
the balcony if you can't see out of it
unless you're standing up
so that's my only comment on this
uh thank you perhaps i was going to come
in and say something there about people
waving to you but i won't hand over to
uh yeah
without sounding too much like a broken
record this evening the motivations of
the applicant are not the consideration
of members of the committee
so the fact that they want it is is is
the merits of it whether or not it's
sufficient as is thanks
thank you
uh and other members
uh council dexter
uh thank thank you mr chairman
um
i have noticed in the
um the notes that um
broadstairs town council unanimously
recorded a vote of no comment
but then we see that uh councillor david
saunders who's a member of that council
has called it in and uh
councillor david saunders is very
qualified in planning matters
and he's and he's called it in because
of an unacceptable overlooking
and loss of privacy now maybe the broad
says town council has got this one wrong
so i would i would suggest a site visit
mr
thank you council dexter are there any
other members to speak
nope
okay right
okay when i put this to the vote which
uh is for approval um with members
please show the hands if they approve
sorry if you didn't hear me those
against
abstentions
so that has
fallen
um
bear with me
um so as as mentioned earlier in terms
of the procedure if if a member wants to
propose a new motion obviously cancer
text you've mentioned a site visit um if
members consider that a member wants to
put forward that motion and then
receives a second then that would be
voted on um
obviously members haven't debated the
application to outline potential reasons
for refusal so i think that would
require debate if it was to move to a
refusal straight away um and so
therefore it's it's whether or not a
member wants to propose for a site visit
uh and and that to be seconded
uh thank you ian um councillor zesky
yeah i'd like to propose a site visit
right i have a propose of a site visit
uh as and said there has been no real
debate um
uh so we've had a proposal councillor
shrub i believe a second for site visit
members do you all agree we have a site
visit
for before yep before and against
anybody against
you a bit quick there chad
was a bit quick
thank you for counseling abstentions
sorry
well it's bruce says isn't it oh yeah
you have sentient thank you councillor
wing i think that was curry i think that
was
it's not football on that day again he's
there it can't be it's out of season oh
very nice too thank you thank you
members so uh a site visit has been
agreed as i mentioned earlier it will be
on friday the
10th of june
at 9 30 so we look forward to coming
over to sunny
process agenda item 4c is the
application for deferral
of numbers 2 to 12 harold road margate
uh speaking in favor of this application
is mr shepherd and again i'm apologizing
for keeping people late but as you hear
obviously
our first item is quite a lengthy uh
debate
uh mr shepard are you there
you have three minutes
uh thank thank you officers and uh
council members um apologies i've never
been in this situation before speaking
so um
generally we've been invested in thanic
for five years now and
we're heavily invested in in the area
we first purchased this site three years
ago
understanding it was
under being put forward for residential
development
we have worked closely with the council
over that three year period to what i
believe
we have come to
a good balanced mix of properties that
looks uh in keeping with the local area
i believe it benefits the surrounding
properties in terms that we've dragged
the building back towards the front of
harold road
we've increased the
volume of green space
and we have i believe as well addressed
all the points under current policy
conditions with the council over that
three year period
um
i'd also think that it would be a good
generation in terms of what the current
site's use is um the volume of the
existing site will be reduced in terms
of its current volume to what we've
proposed and we'll be contributing
towards the
local authorities housing requirements
that i believe at the moment are not
being met so
in terms of those items delivering
a good quality properties
uh increasing the outlook from all the
surrounding neighbors
um
contributing to the council as well
through a section 106 contribution
including schools etc and things like
that and given that the council's got
a good report in terms of us being
compliant with all of the policies i
would respectively hope that you follow
the councils uh sorry the planning
officers recommendations and grant
paying permission for the site thank you
for your time such a late evening
uh thank you mr shepherd uh speaking as
an objector to this application is a
miss leaning miss leaning
yes hi thank you thank you
i'm speaking on behalf of the norfolk
road and harold road residents our first
objection is the developer's admission
in the supplementary planning statement
that the application is not financially
viable to make a section 106
contribution a development of this size
would greatly impact on the neighborhood
community services especially the
already overstretched bethesda medical
center there's no provision of social
housing either and i wonder why astana
is one of the most deprived wards in the
country
the local plan states that this site
have developed should have 10 units on
it and pre-application advice sites no
evidence was submitted to justify why
terrorist housing cannot be provided
this has not changed the plan reads that
architectural designs have been inspired
by the buildings in the areas deemed to
have high architectural designs however
they're not in keeping with the majority
of the adjacent roads which have mainly
victorian houses the internal dimension
of the flats are also exceedingly tight
which is essentially poor design
the site itself is significantly lower
than norfolk road so the proposal of a
1.8 meter fence at the back of the car
park is inadequate it's unclear how this
will provide any security to the
opposite back gardens
barber court on harold road is also
concerned about similar security and the
structural integrity of their garden
walls additionally it's very unclear
what is proposed at the juncture between
harold road and norfolk road as
currently there is no access due to an
existing large building um but in the
plan it will simply be a meter high
hedge with no consideration of security
or access sort of between the two roads
and we don't feel this is acceptable um
in the initial application the police
firmly rejected the plan due to the car
park being a concealed courtyard which
would be a potential crime hotspot while
the latest proposal has added security
gates the car park is still
fundamentally concealed and will require
significant security lighting
norfolk road is a dark sky space with
quite an abundance of wildlife the
biodiversity report stated that to
minimize impact there should be bat
friendly lighting and no lighting near
any trees
given my above point about the need for
security and lighting in a concealed car
park these two issues create a lose-lose
situation
noise and light pollution from the car
park will impact wildlife and residents
opposite primarily back bedrooms and the
one tree on harold road will be cut down
for this development and leave
uninspiring hard block street
architecture regarding fire safety
there's no evidence of any assessment
having been carried out in relation to
fire access to the proposed three houses
on the norfolk roadside there's little
room to turn into the alley without
losing precious parking spaces on
norfolk road
and the fire brigade has noted it's a
very narrow alley down to those houses
regarding eviction and unemployment in
the initial proposal it stated that
there was no eviction and no
unemployment being would occur but the
site had four viable businesses and a
house with 15-year tenured tenants
regarding parking there's only one
parking space per flat and five visitor
parking and yet they're two to three
bedroom flats this is really inadequate
and will impact on on the surrounding
roads which already struggle with
parking
this area is um
surrounded by conservation areas this
area of cliftonville which is cited in
the local plan as being beneficial to
cliftonville they've also received a
significant amount of town deal money um
was awarded to the area and yet there
doesn't seem to be a holistic view on
the planning in total but this could be
a chance to rectify this issue thank you
uh thank you um also um objecting to
this application is that mr bryant mr
bryant please
um i've been living with my family at 20
norfolk road for 25 plus years in peace
and tranquility if the side and back of
our property comes an access road for
proposed properties it will severely
impact on our well-being therefore we
object for the following reasons our
semi-detached home will be surrounded on
three sides by light noise and pollution
24 7.
my wife grandson who lives with us and
myself will suffer respiratory
conditions diagnose and treat to
prescribe inhalers my wife's very severe
and triggered by allergens particular
car fumes we will not be able to open
our windows and the pollution will
exacerbate these conditions when these
conditions are exacerbated the knock-on
effect is disabling for us lots of
function lots of being able to work
i'm a military veteran and a war
pensioner having served 22 years in the
infantry so extremely concerned and
anxious regarding extra noise which will
come from the new build houses to the
back of our property and the side access
road
noise such as car doors closing reverend
engines loud music people partying
talking arguing shouting and having
barbecues if cooking pork is the causes
flashbacks from numerous active service
tours the smell of pork is the same soil
as human bodies burning relaxing in my
garden and my conservatory are my quiet
safe place after work for downtime and
my well-being
therefore air noise and light pollution
and social behavior to side rear of our
property from vehicles and pedestrians a
big concern
we are private people we feel closed in
by the proposed development and
long-term consequences of it
the narrow side access
is
10 foot 4 inches wide
enough for two vehicles not enough for
two vehicles to pass an average sized
car is five foot ten and the van is
seven seven foot six
if the side access is granted who will
please it who will own it who'll
maintain it issues such as flight
tipping which already occurred car
dumping
car maintenance taking place drug use
bin collection lighting all need to be
considered
the gate proposed in the plan is not at
the top of the road therefore
will not stop the access being used
unsocially or at night in the dark this
represents a security concern for us
the noise of the gate continue opening
and closing and who will maintain it and
guarantee that tenants will use it
boundaries
water number 2016 have already been
removed this is a health and safety
matter i have photo evidence of the two
foot five retaining wall which has been
removed at the rear raft property photos
showing the retaining walls along the
side access roads which have been also
removed these walls are not safely
secure the landing properties from euros
and then collapse
when these retaining walls are rightly
reinstated there will be less room for
cars to move maneuver and park in
proposed plan
the proposed new house will generate
more traffic and noise on norfolk roads
and use up street parking space due to
difficulty with the side road being too
narrow and navigating proposed cars
parking bays to be difficult
my wife and i are nurses working for the
nhs so we always need our access parking
out the front of our car
i'm worried concerned about street
parking or really extreme concern of
traffic impact with an extra existing
large build currently ongoing on norfolk
road
i do believe this development represents
over development one family three-story
property could be built at number 18
within keeping in line with current
properties with a garden to the rear and
space for off-road parking at the front
it would sell very quickly in today's
property market it would also be more in
keeping the concern
conservation of gryffindorville the
proposal of elementary access via
hardware could be cul-de-sac and
type developed with houses and gardens
which back onto the gardens of norfolk
road property again i believe these
properties would be highly sought after
thank you mr bryant
also
as an objective for this application mrs
munt if you're there please
hello my name is mrs laurie month
my husband and i and our children have
lived in cliftonville for 29 years and
have been in harold road in the flat
above st george's garage for 17 years
and brought up our children in this
small area
my husband was born and bred in margaret
and we've seen many changes some good
some not
in the 17 years we've been here we've
seen six blocks of flats built
and it feels as if we're going back to
flats flats everywhere
as it is as a massive empty building in
godwin road and this has been the case
for years now
would it not be prudent to convert those
instead of harming the environment and
contributing to climate change there is
also an empty plot the old butlins hotel
with a sea view could that not be built
on would these not be more suitable
instead of knocking down a lovely old
building that has much history and has
had successful businesses and that are
part of the community
at least one of the businesses now
cannot carry on because the new landlord
will not fix the roof in the hope of
being able to develop
essentially purposely putting the
business in a position where they cannot
go on to benefit themselves
we also have trouble with anti-social
behaviour and only recently on good
friday my husband and myself had to
sweep glass off the pavement and garage
property because 10 drinking teenagers
decided instead of putting their bottles
in the bin they would smash them all
my husband did contact the police and
this is just one example of whether we'd
have to do this
new property also means a huge demand on
schools doctors can't get through on the
phone which is already an issue dentists
can't get one already again an issue and
other services
and as the water company can't stop
releasing raw sewage into the sea how
will more flats and the odd house or two
affect their services not only the above
but on a personal level if we are forced
to move we would be homeless because we
don't have any family to rely on and
there is a lack of social housing in the
area
and we do not have this option to turn
to the council has previously said they
didn't want any more flats built because
they wanted to attract more families
howard road is a diverse road and the
people are friendly and i feel that more
flats would bring a chaos to an
overpopulated area
why is it that local families can't
afford anywhere because the flats are
aimed at out-of-towners and they are
priced out and the rental market is
unfair to local families as well because
the rent is almost the same as london
prices
thank you for your time and listening
thank you very much i'm not going to
hand over to
emma who's going to outline the planning
application emma
thank you chairman uh the application
site is outlined in red on this plan so
this is hard road on the left-hand side
here
on the right-hand side here you can see
this is norfolk road and to the top of
the plan is eastern esplanade
and the site lies just outside of the
conservation area so cliff top
conservation area is located um to the
north of the site and the norfolk road
conservation area is located to the east
of the site
the site also lies within
the cliftonville renewal area
so this is just some aerial views of the
site so the site is currently occupied
by a garage that provides
servicing and mot use so these are the
existing buildings on the site so this
is the
boundary of the application site here
so these buildings running up to the
edge of the boundary
and then this four core area to the
front and the side here
um there's two accesses currently into
the site so there's an access from north
uh from howard road
at the bottom of this slide and there's
an existing access from norfolk road
into the application site
so this is just a a closer view of the
existing buildings within the site so
there these are um
high single story buildings with picture
roofs and at the front of the site are
two story buildings
this is just another view of the
building so the application site is this
building
here with the pitch roof and the
buildings behind it and this building on
the right hand side here and it's the
whole of this area here with the fork
and again this area here with um before
call for parking
and then this is taken from norfolk road
looking towards the site so this at the
bottom of the slide here is the existing
access that runs to the sites that's
currently used by the existing business
um into the site and then again you can
see the the buildings um in in the
within the site so all of these
buildings are proposed to be demolished
as part of the application
and then this is again just taken
looking towards norfolk road and so you
can see some of the neighboring
properties that are concerned that back
on to the development site in norfolk
road
again the edge of the boundary is this
location here
so these are some photos now of the
sites this is taken from howard road
looking at the application site so this
is the existing garage building
and then further um to the north looking
towards it so again you can see the
garage building at the front that's two
story it then drops in height um along
the the remainder of the site and then
you can see another two story building
in this location here and the forecourt
for parking to the front of the site
this again shows the forklift area more
detail so there's um two trees within
the site that you can see in this
location here and it is
intended to retain these trees as part
of the application there's a tree off to
the left here which is actually within
the neighboring site
and then a further view taken off the
application site again so you can see
there's existing access into the site
from harold road
and then now we're going um south along
harold road looking towards the
application site
so you can see the style of the
properties within the site so there are
some quite traditional looking
properties with pitched roofs and bay
windows in terms of heights you can see
that there's a three and a half story
building um to the south of the
application site and there's also
two-story buildings and then you can see
there's also examples of flat
developments at um three to four stories
in height as well and so this is just
off to the south of the application site
and then you can see beyond that again
more traditional looking properties but
again three to four stories in height
along the road
and then this is now looking from um the
south um towards the application site on
the right hand side so opposite the site
is an existing garage use and you can
see along
eastern espinarde is an existing
four-story and flat block
again looking on the other side of the
road this is the left of the garage
opposite the site so again you can see
the starter properties
there's a variation there's terrace
blocks there's semi-detached and
detached units
and there's a difference in roof styles
of some with pitch roofs and some have
parapets with setback pitch roofs
there's a real
variety in the start of properties along
the road
and then this is looking now from the
north um from closer to eastern
esplanade so this is now um close within
the conservation area so this would be
the view from the conservation area
looking towards the application site
which is in this location here
and then again further down looking
towards the application site which is on
the left hand side
and here you can see um the existing
flat block within eastern esplanade
which is four stories in height
and again a further view of that flat
block
this is now within norfolk road
which is the the parallel road so this
is the
existing access into the application
site
and then a further view here so there's
a ground level change from um norfolk
road into the site so the site does drop
down in level um a section plan has been
produced and it does show that there's
approximately a one meter ground level
change from the road level to the actual
application site and you can see again
the style of properties within norfolk
road mainly pitch roofs there's a very
variety again three stories and some
two-story properties
and then this is a closer view looking
down that access road towards the
existing buildings which are to be
demolished
and you can see here the the way the
ground slopes into the site
so this is the existing block plan
showing the extent of the site that's
covered by existing development so you
can see the um two-story building is
coming at the front and then you can see
the fact it's
entirely covered um in this area here by
and the existing buildings with this
area here being the forecourt
and then this is the proposed layout
plan so you can see that
the proposal is to
fully demolish all of those buildings
with a flat development in this location
here and then
the erection of three units in this
location here to be accessed from
norfolk road
so this application has had a lot of
negotiation we've had a previous
application which was withdrawn
and then through this current
application there's also been further
negotiation that's taken place so just
to
take you through the plans that we've
been considering so the original
application of the previous um the
previous application what was this plan
so this showed
an application for
45 units which included 41 flats and
four houses so in this location here was
the 41 flats and this was the four
houses accessed from norfolk road
we had concerns with this application
due to the depth of the building
the impact on the conservation area the
limited amenity space
um and the height of the building
so you can see here this was the
original elevation plans that we were
considering which showed um a five-story
building with accommodation at roof
level um it was very clearly a flat
block development
and these were this is the rear
elevation which um had
balconies on it and this is the side
view so this is looking towards
looking towards the conservation area so
this is the view that we would have had
of the development because it's quite a
deep
deep building and then this was a view
to the south so concerns were raised
with that and that application was
withdrawn we then had um
so i'll just show you also these were
the four houses that were accessed from
norfolk roads so they were originally
three stories a full three stories in
height as well
so this
plan was then submitted through this
current application
and so we this then dropped the number
of units from 45 down to 42 units um
this proposal is for was for 39 flats
with three houses accessed from norfolk
road
again we still had concerns regarding
the lack of immunity space and the depth
of the building
and this was the elevation that was
submitted in terms of the street
elevation so you can see that there was
actually a fifth floor on top of the
building as well located to the center
and there was um some concerns with with
the design of the building and the fact
it didn't have enough vertical emphasis
and these were the side views so this
side on the left hand side is a view
that you would have seen from the
conservation area so there's some
concern with the lack of staggering
within this elevation and the um
lack of windows and the the stock design
that you would have got from viewing it
from the conservation area
so this is now the application that is
now before you so this has now reduced
the number of units down to 37 units um
so this is now for 34 flats and for
three houses
the 34 flats includes 26 two bed eight
three bed and then there's three four
bed houses at the rear
and you can see that there's now a
deeper communal meeting space that
serves the units in terms of parking
there's 33 parking spaces to the rear
and five parking spaces to the front um
which results in one space um per flat
plus an additional four parking spaces
and then for the three houses there's
two parking spaces per unit
now the site is a very deep site it can
accommodate um a large development um
you would have seen from actually if i
just sorry flick back through to um
[Music]
the aerial view sorry a bit far back
actually sorry
sorry too far back
if you can if you look at this view you
can see in terms of the sites in harold
road all of the sites in harvard are
extremely deep there's lots of examples
where we've previously approved
developments at the rear um where
there's been conversions of buildings
and when there's been new build um
houses built at the rear because of the
fact the site is so deep so in terms of
pattern of development um the site can
accommodate a larger building and it can
accommodate development at the rear and
that would be considered to be in
keeping with the passenger development
that you can see within harold road
sorry
it was bad planning
then this is a closer view of the block
plan and so you can see
in closer detail the layout you can see
that there's a bin storage area within
this location here which will be
accessed from harold road there's a
cycle store area um in this location
here
um for the house at the back this is um
the the access with a bin collection
point in this location here and some
setback home gates into the site you can
see um to the top here these are the
trees that are being retained as part of
the application so they're located
within the immunity space
the building's set back in line with the
existing front elevation of the property
to the south at number 1416 harold road
so it follows the existing building line
you can see it's quite a staggered front
elevation
and this again just shows um the parking
spaces there's electric vehicle charging
within the rear area
and again you can see the the
refuge store areas and a setback gate
within this central area so this is our
undercroft that goes under the building
accessed from howard road
with some setback gates
so this is now the proposed front
elevation
so in terms of its design it's
it's not overly traditional but it does
respect some of the characteristics of
buildings within within the road it's um
red and um yellow bricks building you
can see that the front elevation where
it's staggered it's now provides quite a
vertical emphasis along the building so
it gives the appearance of separate
blocks rather than one just one large
block so that's characteristic of the
road where there are individual mainly
individual properties within the road in
terms of fenestration you can see the
quite large
modern
windows with
floor-to-ceiling glaze in which does
help to add interest to the front
elevation
in these locations here there are
projections like bay projections which
again respect the fact that there's a
number of bay projections on properties
within the street
so zinc cladding is being used on those
elements which again helps add interest
to the front elevation and at the top
floor here this is not um a picture if
this is still um part of like flush with
the front of the building but by using
the cladding at this top level it gives
the appearance of a dropped ease level
between the blocks
and then this is a proposed rear
elevation so it's similar in appearance
there's a few
balcony areas to the center here but
mostly it's just balconettes or and
again the floor to ceiling glazing is
provided
and then these are the side elevations
so this side elevation on the right the
south facing elevation that face is a
neighboring property there's only a
small gap in between so this view
wouldn't really be that visible within
the street the north facing elevation is
the view from the conservation area and
this is now a very staggered elevation
so the closest point of this is the the
yellow brick element and the part on the
right of that and on the left of that
they're then in line with one another
and this rear section is set much
further back so in terms of the view
that you would get standing in the
street it would mainly be of this front
section and then this section here and
potentially this section but you
wouldn't really get much of a view from
this one given the setback so that has
really helped reduce the depth of the
building as viewed from the conservation
area
this is the proposed ground floor plan
so in terms of the size of the units the
green colored flats are the three bed
units they're all located at the rear of
the building each of the units meets the
minimum space standards for the the size
unit
this is the first floor plan showing the
units and the second so you can see
there's three units here at the back
that have the balconies but none of the
buildings closest to the neighbours on
um to the south have any balconies
and then there's the third floor plan
and then going back to the site plan
just to show you now the
elevations of the houses which are
located in the south here so this is the
front elevation of the terrace houses so
concerns being raised from residents
regarding potential overlooking from
these units so we have sort of mended
plans that have removed the dorm windows
that were located within the roof and
replaced those with velox windows so
this is whilst it's in the description
as a three-story building it's only
two-story to ease level and now at top
roof level it's um v-locks is within the
roof in order to reduce any perception
of overlooking um and there's also the
ground level reduction
of the one meter to these buildings so
i'll show you later the section plan you
can see the impact on the neighbours but
in terms of the actual design these are
pitched roof the red and yellow brick
again to tie in with the um material and
pallet materials from the original
building um the windows are slightly
smaller the upvc um grey windows
and then this is the rear elevation this
has maintained the the dormer at the
rear
and then this is the the ground floor
plan of the unit
and you can see there's two bedrooms at
first floor and two bedrooms at second
floor
this is a street elevation so showing
the existing site which is on the top of
the slide so you can see the existing
garage in this location here and the
units behind it and then you can see the
proposed development so whilst there
again has been concerned from residents
regarding the scale of the building and
the depth of the building it does
actually tie in quite nicely within the
street scene in terms of the height it's
not particularly out of character with
and the scale and height of other
buildings within the area
as you saw from the photos there's a
number of terraced buildings within the
street so again in terms of the width of
the building where it's broken up to
give the appearance almost of terrorist
units within the block this would mean
it would appear quite in keeping with
the character of the area
and then this is just to show now the
impact on the neighbours
so um the main neighbors affected is um
barber court which is in this location
here so number 14 to 16.
so there's a 2.6 metre gap between the
proposed development and the side
elevation of that neighbouring property
and then at this point here the building
sets away from the boundary to creating
a distance of 4.4 meters to the
neighboring property
um
and then this section of the building
does extend beyond the rear elevation of
number 14 to 16 by 5.4 meters but you
can see given that distance in terms of
looking at a fortified degree line from
the nearest neighboring window from that
property the development would not
actually um breach that 45 degree line
and therefore the impact on light and
outlook to these neighbor properties is
considered to be acceptable there's no
side facing windows within this
elevation so there's no any there's no
direct overlooking of those properties
um darwin court which is the big flat
block that's on eastern esplanade is in
this location here there's a distance of
um 20
meters from the nearest window within
the side elevation of the proposed
development and the nearest window
within darwin court so there's no
windows within this elevation their
windows are set back so there's a good
20 meter distance the windows are in
this um side elevation are overlooking a
parking cool area so actually that's it
could almost be argued a benefit to have
some additional natural surveillance of
that space but there's not going to be
any um any real overlooking concerns of
the neighbouring property
there's a communal amenity space in this
location here that serves darwin cool so
there would be some views from these
windows in this location here towards
that communal space there's a distance
of nine meters to that communal space
however the communal space is not a
private area and it's also screened by
the trees which are to be retained and
there's not considered that there will
be any significant concern regarding
overlooking to those properties
um in terms of the properties on norfolk
road and there's a distance of 24 meters
from the front elevation of the three
terrace units to the rear elevation of
the properties in norfolk roads that's
quite a considerable distance anyway
then on top of that as mentioned we've
um sought to amend the front elevation
to remove the dormer and replace that
with a velux window so that's reduced
the perception of overlooking and then
this is now the section plan that's been
produced that shows the relationship
between the the terrorist units and the
property in norfolk road so norfolk road
is on the left hand side you can see
that the ground level of the access is
is reducing
and therefore in terms of the ease level
of the proposed development it is lower
than the east level of the buildings in
norfolk road and therefore given the
distance and the dropping ground level
and the amendment as the remove the
dormer it's considered that the impact
on the privacy of these properties is
acceptable
um concern has been raised um i think
regarding the
boundary fences and the potential
concerns regarding that because there's
a retaining wall that was in this
location here i believe that's probably
the wall that was mentioned that there's
been some removal of of the retaining
wall so where there are some ground
level changes across the site and there
is some concern about what height fences
um would be erected around the parking
areas we have um put a condition on the
consent that would look for details of
the levels of the site to come in so
that we can understand what boundary
treatment height is necessary in order
to avoid any overlooking or any concerns
regarding noise and disturbance from the
parking area to the neighbours and to
make sure there's a structurally sound
boundary serving the neighbouring
properties
in terms of access highways have raised
no concerns with the access so this
accesses the existing access is in this
location here so it's moved slightly so
it's
a new drop curve in this location
there's adequate pedestrian visibility
displays you can see from the five
parking spaces to the front these also
have adequate pedestrian visibility and
therefore there's no concerns regarding
the actual safety of the access or the
parking spaces in terms of the access to
the rear isn't existing access so
there's no concerns regarding the use of
that existing access concern has been
raised from residents and regarding
vehicle movements and the potential
increase from
vehicles using the site so um a
transport statement was submitted with
the application that looked at trip
generation the existing use of the site
is as an mit garage and therefore
there's a lot of vehicles that would
currently use the the site um the
existing vehicle trips that were
assessed uh were 223 vehicle trips
across a 12 hour period when looking at
the proposed use and this was actually
based on the original
number before it was amended um it
looked at
97 vehicle trips across 12 hours so
there's actually potentially going to be
a reduction of 126 vehicle trips as a
result of this proposed residential
development when compared to the
existing garage use so given that the
impact on highway safety is considered
to be acceptable
so
the issues are with this site the site
is an allocated housing site within the
sanic local plan it's allocated for a
notional 10 units although
what we need to look at is potentially
the optimum use of the land and when
there's no other um material
considerations that would say otherwise
we we could look at increasing that
number of units so it's not set within
the policy it's just a
potential number
the site also falls though within the
cliftonville development plan where we
would encourage larger family units and
we would object to any one bed unit so
there's no one bed units within the
development
and there is a mix of units so there are
the two bed flats three bed flats and
the four bed houses across the site um
we did initially
encourage the developer to come forward
with a housing scheme and i'll go over
that later but that's to do the concerns
with that to do with viability and but i
will come on to that later
in terms of the actual number of units
um
we we have a lack of
five year supply of housing and
therefore any increase in number of
units would be encouraged unless there's
any environmental harm that would
say otherwise
so in terms of looking at the viability
the application came forward initially
with
a proposal for no affordable housing on
site and no off-site contributions
we asked for the viabilities assessment
to come in which has been independently
reviewed
when looking at that assessment um
some concerns were raised with the
figures that were provided and some
negotiation has taken place
and as a result of that we
are now looking at an offer of 125 000
pounds of contributions from the
developer for the application
so in looking at the financial
contributions that have been requested
by consultees um we are looking at
allocating that
to
health care so the ccg request for 30
564 pounds
the contribution will go towards that
which is looking at expansion of
the local medical um practice
and there would be a contribution of 15
542 pounds which would go to the special
education provision
and then um a contribution of 2015
pounds which will go towards waste
improvements of the waste recycling
centre this leaves a remaining in amount
of 76
877 pounds which would go towards an
affordable housing offsite contribution
which would be used towards um
affordable housing provision in the
local area
and so it's considered that on on
balance with the viability assessment
has been carried out that this is an
acceptable um approach to put forward to
members um through that viability
assessment an option for 10 houses was
um considered so we did actually have a
independent review by um our consultants
of a 10 unit um scheme and the
consultants did agree that to try and
put 10 houses on the site was an
unviable option and therefore it would
not come forward as part of a planning
application so obviously members are
considering tonight this application
which is for um the mixed flat
development with houses um scheme
so the site is pre pre-developed land so
it is the site that we would be looking
to support housing on and encouraged to
come forward for for housing development
um
it it will achieve a
a number of units that will contribute
towards our housing supply in terms of
the design we consider that the design
as now amended is acceptable and has
limited impact on the conservation area
and the setting of the conservation area
and will appear in keeping with the the
street scene and the character
appearance of of of howard road
in terms of the impact on neighbours we
feel that this has now been adequately
addressed and that through the
amendments the impact on on neighboring
immunity is acceptable
and there's no concerns regarding
highways or any other
concerns from other council teas so it
is recommended that the application is
um deferred and delegated for approval
subject to the receipt of the legal
agreement securing the financial
contributions which will include the spa
contribution as well
and safeguarding conditions so thank you
uh thank you very much emma i move the
officer's recommendation is adopted
could the vice chair please second i'll
second that yeah thank you council
coleman cook members
because crindlin
thank you um most of my questions have
been answered but uh given that these
are family-sized units the flats um is
the bin storage
does it meet the minimum requirements to
be adequate for
the number of family-sized units that
you've got there
well we have consulted with waste and
recycling and they've raised no concerns
with it they're quite happy that it's
easily accessible and they have looked
at the plans and they have raised no
concerns with the waste provision
i think it was more as to whether or not
the size is adequate uh for the number
of people that it needs to that are
going to be producing the rubbish um or
is there going to be overflow
um well
it's quite a large area what we would
look at for units of of this number is
probably more the larger units with the
rather than individual bins that you get
for houses so the in terms of the size
of um the refuge store there they would
add adequately be able to um provide a
large number of those larger um
waste bins so yeah we consider it
acceptable
thank you council keene
thank you
i think it's over development i think
it's a poor design for the area which
has a lot of quite classic buildings in
it and i have a number of concerns about
it
um
i wonder how much play space there is
for a development that would potentially
have a lot of young children around i
don't know if you can give me any
measurements on exactly how much
communal play space there would be
i wonder how many cycles could be stored
again for the number of residents that
there are
potentially in this development you know
how many cycles store storage is
available
according to the report there should be
nine visitor parking bays and there
aren't
you've just said about the bins
does the assessment that there's going
to be enough bin space include recycling
facilities
um and finally yet again we're told
there's you know not viable for
affordable housing social housing and
yet that is what we desperately need and
i think developers need to come up with
plans that actually are viable and can
still contribute to our total
thank you
can you come back on the questions
please thank you emma
um in terms of the cycle storage the
cycle store would provide um 34 bikes so
one per unit
and in terms of the immunity space the
larger community space to the rear of
the flats
is um 21 meter approximately 21 meters
by 8 meters in size
and then for the houses it's 11.5 by 4.5
um so as you know we don't have a policy
that actually sets out a minimum size
standard for immunity space it's just a
matter of considering the plan and
whether we consider that the size is
usable
and um whether it's overlooked obviously
this space
through the amended plans the one of the
original mended plans um well the very
original had hardly any immediate space
the second one that we looked at through
the um
first submission had the central section
of the larger building projecting right
into the middle of the space so it would
have made it quite disconnected so we've
asked for the setback of that central
section in order to create quite a a
wide area of immediate space that's
really usable for um children within the
development and then that would also be
secured with
fencing around it in order to make it
safe from the parking area
and waste and recycling when they look
at it look at housing developments they
have particular standards for both
recycling and waste in terms of the bins
that are required
and in fact the council is working on a
specific spd which will enshrine that in
planning guidance but we do apply the
requirements that they provide to ensure
there's enough
and they are very keen to tell us when
we haven't done that so we are quite
confident in in what's been put forward
thank you chad
council heart did you please
thank you chair um
i'm
terribly appalled by this um
development i think it's over
development on the site i don't think
any thought has been given to the
conservation area or the houses locally
and i must agree with councillor keane
um
i just don't think there's enough
amenity space there's not enough parking
you're expecting all of these people
just to have 30 cars one each and it
just doesn't happen there's just not
enough space there's not enough parking
in that road anyway and i think that to
have a building that's four stories high
um in an area where most the windows are
three stories or two um there's no
comprehension of trying to keep those
windows in line at all there's just
trying to get as much into this site as
as possible and the fact that there's no
social housing is an absolute disgrace
absolute disgrace and i must admit i
can't approve this this application at
all i'm awfully sorry uh thank you
councillor council garner
thank you yeah i mean i listened to
councillor keane and i agree with
everything that she said and i would and
council heart and i would like to
emphasize the fact that we have on a
number of occasions that this committee
had applications before us that haven't
provided the right amount of affordable
housing as stated in the local plan
we've seen a number of very very long
viability
statements that try to justify this but
as far as i'm concerned and i think as
far as a lot of us concerned if a
development can't provide thirty percent
affordable housing then the development
is not viable and i won't be supporting
it
thank you guys garner uh miss louis i
just to come back with regards to the
affordable housing policy sp 23 which
specifically talks about when a
development isn't viable uh that the
affordable housing if it's been proved
that it's not viable doesn't have to be
provided as long as that evidence is
there
it was the key issue in the public
inquiry about the shonde road inquiry
and in that case it was clearly found
that that the evidence that was produced
was acceptable we are rigorous with our
checks about this its particular
provision is made within the local plan
to ensure that development does come
forward
you know a viable development comes
forward and we will always try and
maximize the the right amount of
affordable housing but there are some
developments that will come forward
that won't provide affordable housing
only if the evidence is there in this
instance this is a brownfield site and
what that means is that there is an
existing use value that is accrued from
it being a garage and that needs to then
be compared with the gross development
value of this development when you take
away then the costs of building it which
gives you the residual land value in
that instance the comparison between
getting the site to come forward
uh that money that would take to
basically sell the land then compared to
that residual land value and that's when
a development may be unviable if that
residual land value is too low
now this does happen on brownfield sites
you know if development is wanted for
housing on brownfield sites rather than
in the countryside we need to look at
these sites which is why it's been
allocated the notional number that was
provided um which was performed as as 10
units has clearly been demonstrated to
not be viable and now obviously if if
members were to look to
you know reduce the size of development
that would obviously impact on the
contributions that are
being provided admittedly i appreciate
that's less than is required by the
though has been put forward by uh the
the requirements of the different
consultees
but at the same time the site from the
evidence that we've got that's been
independently assessed
will not come forward for housing
development um if if the number of units
is is reduced so that it's a balance and
i do appreciate it's a difficult
position for members to be in and this
is arguably a new debate that we're
having at committee because usually
we're talking about countryside sites
and it's pretty clear-cut what the
issues would be and the costs actually
are lower but this is one of those
situations where viability is always
going to be looked at in a lot of detail
which is what we've we've done thank you
chair thank you and uh counselor you
wish to come back
thank you chair yeah we all understand
how it works here and when we're when
we're we're intelligent people here um
and we do understand what the developer
wants to achieve and what you want to
achieve we don't we don't
um
take it for granted we're always going
to have the 30 housing we all understand
that however um when you look at that
picture that emma put forward of the
housing either side there terraced
houses they're three and a half two and
a half stories almost three
none of it none of the pictures of that
new building actually run in line with
any of the other properties at all in
any way shape or form and that's what
we're trying to achieve surely in this
sort of
area of conservation okay it's on the
outskirts of it let's just you know i
know a house is three feet away from the
conservation area and the rules are very
different but i mean at the end of the
day what you want to try and achieve is
something which is goes with the local
area and that has had no thought about
that at all in my opinion and that's
what we're here to discuss because we're
all planning uh committee and i don't
think okay we've got a big block on the
left but i mean that's on the c fund
let's be honest about it it's not the
side road per se is it um and with in
respect of that i think if you're going
to try and get all of this
development in you've got to try and
look it look as a an overall scope but i
don't think that achieves it in any way
shape or form i'm sorry
thank you that's a lot um
i'm not going to
dispute in terms of i'll argue the
merits of the case and says obviously
the officer reports put forward what our
view is in terms of the the context to
which this development would sit um and
you're right in terms of looking at that
context and that is indeed what an
inspector would do when looking at
development in this area and obviously
we've talked about that they look at it
in very granular detail i mean we are
very mindful of the mix that is there
and there is a mix and obviously you
mentioned the mccarthy stone development
that you can see on the left hand side
there that's on both sides of the road
and it's a very clear full story that's
in the conservation area might i add um
and
there is there is development that is
very much in this area which we that's
why we think the scale here is
appropriate but i do understand that
design is a is a it has an element of
subjectivity and that's baked into the
judgment that the members are required
to make so um i you know i do accept
that
that's right
thank you jeff um i'm a little bit i'm
surprised
i i i i really think that there is no
it's curry i i'm kind of getting very
fed up with seeing all these
characterless developments um when you
say when when if i were designing
something that was going to fit into the
area it wouldn't be square square boxes
but what i'm worried about is there's no
no reference to any any other than the
electric charging points as to what
energy efficient
things are being put in to the actual
properties
like you know kind of how how they're
going to be heated what sort of what
sort of heating they're going to have
what kind of water water supplies water
tables they're going to have
and i would have thought that now that
would be a perfect opportunity to make
them eco-friendly as well
thank you councillor wright a bit of
discussion up here please
um
i believe i i don't know the number of
top of my head there's a condition with
regards to water efficiency which is one
of the requirements of the local plants
as a water use of water efficiency um
there is
coming forward at a pace requirements
with regards to building regs which will
increase the standards for energy
efficiency above what's currently part l
and will increase it um i think it's by
25 for the future home standards um in
terms of um energy efficiency we again
we we wouldn't say that um
any additional measures that might be
put on so for example i don't want to
cite council heart but i know his view
is to put solar panels on everything
that's not a policy requirement so we
wouldn't be able to require that to
happen in this instance or that's that
sort of thing
thank you ian
castling
yeah at a recent uh save our seas
ramsgate meeting with the southern water
the ceo actually stated that sanity is
the most stressed area
in terms of water in the country
what's their view on this development
because we are drastically increasing
the water usage and the sewerage out of
this site have they expressed any
concerns and uh back in linde council of
council right over there have we got any
water saving uh
methods built into this uh this
development because it is a considerable
increase i would imagine
from from a commercial bit to the size
of this building with a number of people
now living on site and using water and
creating sewage
i think council wing we just
i can pick up the
capacity point rather than southern
water point um it's i found it it's
condition 22
and that's a requirement um it's a bit
of a quirk of the system that actually
you're required to have a planning
condition which means that development
has to conform with building rigs which
is a rarity which is to do with the
meeting at the required technical water
efficiency standards of 110 liters per
person per day now i know that the
debate which again we've had this before
this debate about you know the abilities
to flush twice rather than once but um
but it is it is again building in those
efficiencies as much as we can within
the bounds of what we have um i'm going
to pass to emma with regards to the
drainage element
um so in terms of the drainage um some
of the water were consulted um they
basically agreed the there's a proposal
for a foul drainage to be
um connected via a new private flower
drainage system which will connect to a
manhole within
um
faucet and hardwood road and a manhole
connection and also in within them
norfolk road as well a new manhole
connection they've also advised that
they can provide the foul sewerage
disposal to serve the development and
they could provide a water supply to
serve the development so they they
basically raised no no concerns at all
in terms of um the actual um surface
water drainage i'm not sure if that's
kind of what you were asking as well
um the the proposal at the moment is to
provide um permeable paving for the
parking spaces and soak aways for the
roof um and run off from the roof and
run from the accesses as well so ktc
suds initially did ask for more
information to demonstrate that this
could happen but given the fact it's an
existing site that's currently in use
it's very difficult to carry out those
tests up front so they were satisfied
that a condition that would require a
detailed radio system to come in as part
of a condition was acceptable
thank you catch over it
yeah thank you chad i'm not going to
support this application um because
i have problems with the look of the
building to be honest with you and i
tend to sympathize with the comments
have been made about its appearance in
the street scene
um and obviously i find it
unacceptable frankly that 76 000 pounds
is the contribution which can be put
forward for social housing in the
context of policy and in the context of
the crime need for social housing in
fannie but i would say where i have some
sympathy what mr livingston said is
we can't keep having it both ways if we
don't want to develop the countryside
and i think that most people don't we
can't also say when these sites come
forward that we don't want these
developed either
if this is in the local plan for housing
we have to recognize that and we have to
maybe make some compromises to me this
is too big a compromise and there's a
compromise in terms of the way the
building looks but i think we have to be
honest with the public and also i don't
think that the existing buildings are of
much merit i have to say so whilst i
don't like what's proposed i don't
particularly like the existing either
uh thank you council over it um
i can't see any
any other
speakers
okay members um i think good debate
there um i'm now going to put this
motion
of the officer's recommendation which is
to defer and delegate to offers for
approval to yourselves uh those in favor
please show
to
those against
all right uh abstentions
that has obviously fallen so if you
could bear with me one moment please
yes mr levinson
i presume thank you thank you
um so members have mentioned the
concerns about scalar development um
in terms of the design
um
the the issue is that the debate hasn't
focused on one particular other than
scale
and obviously what we've tried to
explain is why we consider it on the
officer side of things how the
development would would fit in with the
scale of development that is in the area
there are other points that have been
raised with regards to
amenity space
um one thing it's important to mention
obviously this is a major development
the council is required um to determine
major events such as this um however
obviously we are judged as a criteria on
how many major developments are turned
around to appeal and that's why with any
major development when members want to
refuse it i would always suggest that
the clear reasons for refusal are
crystallized to be able to ensure that
we have the best possible case to defend
at a planning appeal to represent your
views
i would suggest the officer
recommendation at this point is that
we are going out on a site visit uh on
the 10th of june and i do think it would
be important to see the context of the
relationship with the neighbouring
properties as well as the relationship
with other buildings around there and if
members after seeing the site
in that basis still consider that it
should be refused which is you know the
overriding issue then obviously then
hopefully a motion could be put forward
which includes the detail of why that
should be refused in terms of whether or
not it's considered to be out of keeping
with particular design points in the
area however it is indeed entirely up to
members
thank you ian um
i i do understand and i think council
reviews
refused it um
so
i will take uh listen to mr livingston i
think um
i with will withdraw this now and
i would like somebody to propose a site
visit i think it makes sense um
uh excuse me um
it's down to this committee i can't
allow
please
uh i'd like a proposal for a site visit
on thank you chuck um
a site visit is all well and good when
you're going to
look at a site which you can comprehend
and try and envisage what is going to go
there i think that this is a site which
is a commercial site and it's very
difficult to try and envisage a huge
block of flats next to
a contemporary building if you so desire
and i don't think a site visit will help
any of us this is my opinion will help
any of us try and gauge that as to what
it will look like because we can see
here what it looks like better than we
can just looking at
the front of a forecourt of a garage to
be fair and i think that by looking at
that as
as counselors we look at that think
that's too big and i don't think by
having a personally i don't think by
having a site with it it's going to help
at all
i will come asking him to come back okay
just to just to confirm
apologies i i may not have been
particularly clear it's it is to ensure
that the context of um the scale has
been considered obviously the scale is
the only point that's been raised by
members in terms of design um again
members if if if a motion is to be put
forward to refuse the application um
then i think it would be um you know it
would be a suggestion that if that
motion was put forward then there would
potentially be an adjournment so we
could work with the member that puts
forward the the motion to be able to
crystallize again that point but
obviously we would normally suggest that
you either go to a site visit or we
bring it back the following month so
that we can best represent your views at
an appeal but again if members want to
refuse it this evening
that is that is your option it will be
about putting the motion forward if
emotions put forward by the chair for a
cybers and that falls emotion can be put
forward to refuse it um with reasons but
again we would just want to support
members in that refusal to make sure
that we're actually able to to
actually argue at an appeal
uh thank you in uh
what i will say is obviously it's been
ian has mentioned this to you regarding
um you know this is a site on the local
plan for housing
and say i'm not going to give an opinion
because i think you know i don't i'm
just stating what
um if this did go for an appeal
um we've got to be very very careful uh
the amount of those major appeals go if
they do go um
for this council i am aware of that um
and i think most of the members here
totally understand what's being said and
you know this is up to the committee
what they say
but
so i'm saying i think we've got to be
very very careful
too many appeals um
we could land ourselves in
a little bit of difficulty if i may say
that i hope i'm not out of all to saying
that
um
yes i will i'm going to council could
not allow you
um yes i wanted to ask uh what scope is
i've heard three main areas of concern
um
the design of the frontage of the
building um and the play space in
particular and the third one's now gone
out of my head um what scope is there uh
to address those concerns and how could
and then come back
um
how can we do that
i understand where you're coming from i
know the applicant is
in the room and i'm not asking him to
ask answer that question at all
but i think i will move on um
because it it is quite a difficult one
again i've listened like we all have uh
and yourselves of your feelings and as i
understand
what you're saying so i i feel
on this occasion at this stage um a site
visit
would be a good thing but i do have to
have a proposal
for that and i can totally understand
what council hart is
saying
i do know the site uh like quite a few
people um
so um
on that i am going to ask for a proposal
for a site visit if anyone is wishing to
will do
that no
okay
we haven't got a proposal so i'm gonna
have to
speak to her
i may check so it's it's remember to put
a motion forward and then to you know
whoever wants to put a motion forward
and potentially for refusal and then
outline the reasons then a second and
then we can try and um we'll work with
you to ensure that we can capture that
casagana
yeah i think the main we
have field and i think a number of us do
that one of the main reasons we we've
refusing this is because of the lack of
affordable housing and the inadequacy of
the affordable housing contribution and
i'd like to be able
i'd like us to be able to
carve a refusal reason around that would
it be possible we i mean i think we're
quite
not quite unanimous but we're quite
a large majority against this
on those grounds would it be possible
to ask you
to come back to try and represent our
views around that and come back to the
next planning committee meeting with the
formulation of words
that we can then agree so as we can
formulate that refusal i mean we are
quite clear
we are refusing this application
as as i think
um
illustrated by the fact that none of us
want a site visit
we are refusing it and we'd like you if
possible to come back to put
put some very
nice planning words that would be well
supportable at the possible appeal
for us to agree to thank you for that
council ghana
and we can write a report that
provides you know potential reasons for
refusal along the lines that have been
suggested
they want the the point to do with
affordable housing again
this comes back to the exact reason
that's been put forward for the shot and
road appeal there is we've looked at the
evidence it's been independently looked
at about the viability the policy
is very clear and
again the only reason why we were able
to defend costs in the shondane road
situation is by getting various
additional viability evidence to argue
and and the
which in itself obviously had a cost
element
in this instance it's it's a lot more
clear-cut because
there is an existing use value on the
site um and that has been looked at and
there has already been debate so
i i think
i understand that members clearly would
like to refuse the application um i
think that the key reasons that have
been put forward are the design
uh the lack of a lack of play space for
the units and the lack of affordable
housing those are the three things so i
think to to resolve the matter if if the
suggestion would be or proposed by
someone that we bring you a report which
goes through those three issues it will
give you our view on those and what you
can and can't refuse on in our view and
then members can decide no we don't
agree with you we'll refuse on all of
them no we'll refuse it on two of them
three of them one of them
thank you again for that um if because
i'm happy to prepare that um proposal
but i also would like to put in the fact
that it's out of keeping with the area
and i think that'll be taking into
account the design
we do understand all of us understand
how you work out affordable housing that
doesn't mean to say that we agree with
it
um but that's our personal opinion
that's why you have a planning committee
we understand what you said earlier that
it's not a viable product in this case
we would like it to be but we also want
it
done in a way that this really isn't in
keeping and i'm happy to propose what
you put forward in because i think
that's the way to go because that's
probably the only way i get refused
uh appeal or carry out appeal
thank you for that council heart um so i
have a proposal could i have a second a
couple of hands yeah i'm quite happy to
second i'm sorry i think there was an
added added thing we did talk about
over development as well
um
that would be it's part of the issue
with design so it's intrinsic yeah
okay um so could i have a show of hands
please that this will be brought back to
yourselves with those recommendations
that is unanimous
thank you members i know that's been a
little bit confusing and uh so far but
thank you um
that concludes the business for this
evening
yeah could i ask for some clarification
on on the residents speaking because on
the item concerning births four i know i
know
only one resident was allowed to talk
and yet we've just had three residents
talk on this last item can you capture
the council why the rules were different
councillor wing i think you are
they
can they that can be clarified but um i
believe you know
councillors can book in on the night if
you like if they're you know 20.1
uh but it is advisable for members it
was about residents only one resident
it has to work
thank you members and
good night